everybody and welcome to mid-suffolk
development control B
my name is Kathy Guthrie and I'm the
chair today may I first of all remind
you of some domestic arrangements please
ensure that microphones are muted when
you are not speaking
a video turned off that you do not
interrupt the other speaker members are
reminded not to use the messaging emojos
chat function during the meeting unless
it is to report a pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest or to notify the
chair that you wish to make a proposal
members are reminded they should not
have alternative communication lines
open I.E other team chats and that if
you are contacted by a third party
during an application you should bring
this to the legal advisors attention
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
Additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by myself please
await your turn we will not be using the
hands up function except for
Declarations of Interest site visits
requests Declarations of lobbying and
questions for clarity and as has been my
Norm for the first part of debate I'll
do the A to Z and then we'll go to hands
up after the first round of that
we will be using electronic voting for
this meeting if you are experiencing
poor connection issues in the first
instance please turn off your camera if
this does not work please turn off all
incoming video
these options are under the three dots
on the main information bar
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except whether
a confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and the possible use of
those sound recordings for webcasting
and all training purposes
the council members of the public and
press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
so the introductions
I will come to that shortly counselor
um the introductions in Dupree legal
advisor
thank you very much I think that's very
appropriate that we do see who you are
good idea thank you Robert Carmichael
the governance officer
you want to show your face I think
that's a very good idea good morning
chair
thank you Philipp Isbell Chief planning
officer
good morning chairman good morning Steve
Grant strategic projects and delivery
manager
good morning chef good morning to you
and we have John pateman G and Gemma
Walker who are both area planning
managers and I'll let you both go
whoever wants to go first or both
together
there we are good morning and Bron
Curtis
um case officer
also for one of our cases here where are
you Bron do you have a picture
that Brawn is on hold at the moment so
she's not here at the right at this
second all right okay thank you we also
have our Ward members now I'll ask you
to introduce yourselves when you come
forward because a couple of them have
left the meeting for the moment
counselor vinya haddingham councilor
John Matheson councilor Dave Muller and
councilor Terrence Carter and they will
all be representing their areas so can I
move on to the agenda please apologies
for absence and substitutions
thank you chair none received
so can you just confirm attendance
through the committee please
thank you chair if members could please
respond with good morning or present
so
counselor Carson
president counselor Gould
present councilor Guthrie
present councilor Humphries present
councilor melon
president councilor Norris
Horizon Council Stringer president and
councilor ball boys
present thank you chair we're all here
thank you so to receive Declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members please
any in the hands-up function councilor
Stringer were you telling me something
earlier or not yes it was yes uh I have
an opportunity interest in Item B as my
father-in-law lives opposite the site
thank you and Mr Clarity is your oh yes
your hands-up signal is working here
that's okay I was a bit worried in case
it wasn't that's fine anybody else
no so Declarations of lobbying
um
so this is um a
non-pecunery and quite a vague interest
but in the interest of transparency I
had a meeting yesterday with belway
homes to discuss the reserve matters on
a um completely different application
um we um we did we um did acknowledge
the fact that they were in this meeting
but no conversation was had whatsoever
about this application but I was in a
meeting with belway homes yesterday
thank you for that councilor Kirsten and
um in to pray can you just confirm yes
indeed I I heard all that that's
absolutely fine that's not no
impropriety there but it is wise to
declare it for transparency
thank you very much and if you can take
your hand down now that's lovely thank
you very much so we move on to the
Declarations
thank you councilor Humphries
um also non-quenary interest
um I'm a town councilor on the planning
committee of the Town Council so when it
comes to The Stone Market gun cotton way
I do have a non-pecuniary interest but I
don't think it prevents me from voting
thank you and councilor Stringer have
you got your hand up again yes I have
yes uh councilor councilor Caston uh I
have a similar I have also in the last
week I think had a meeting with belway
homes on a totally separate matter and
this particular application was not
mentioned
thank you for that thank you very much
very clear
right so we're all done with that one
well done so now Declarations of
lobbying and I can declare that I've
been lobbied
um by the uh
groups safe on fresing field
um I've also had an email regarding
Union Road so that's myself and then I
noticed councilor Caston and councilor
Humphreys in that order please
yeah
on which on which application councilor
Gaston exactly the same as you've just
stated Madam chairman
and councilor Humphries
mum sure thank you exactly the same
thank you and councilor did I see
councilman Norris did you have your end
up oh yes I did thank you my hand up
function seems to be very intermittent
this morning
yeah I've been lovied on 7B and 7c thank
you thank you and um I'm
struggling to get the the
play here councilor Mellon you seem to
want to tell us about something as well
if you would please
yes thank you chair I've been lobbied on
all three applications and I should also
just mention that I have like um
counselor Stringer had meetings with
bellway in fact the same meeting
um but this this application was not
discussed all right okay so that's for
the previous um declaration there thank
you for that and councilor Gould thank
you and exactly the same as yourself uh
chair those two applications thank you
thank you very much can those put your
hands down that I've had your hands up
and I'll see if I can see any more can
you see any more Robert have I missed
anyone
yeah and can everyone else put their
hands down please cancel the wall boys
yes just to record the type being
lobbied on um present field one house
and
I haven't been lobbied on the last one
thank you Council of War boys and have I
missed anyone are we there
can everyone take their hands down
because they seem to be still hands up
on my screen I don't know if you've got
that
anyway
perhaps you can assist me on that as we
move forward because I don't want to
miss people
right so Declarations of personal site
visits um please help me on that because
I've got hands up from the last one so I
don't know
I might share my hands up actually
yeah
no problem um it's the one house I
obviously live very close to it so I sit
every day and I'm fully aware of that
development
thank you very much
because the hands-up functions being a
bit difficult um if anyone else has got
anything do they want to just call out
and we'll pick you up no
right so that's that one personal site
visits uh confirmation of the minutes of
the meeting held on the 3rd of February
now do we have any points of accuracy on
what is contained in those minutes
please
is there anyone showing any desire to
do anything Robert
because I can't see I think my hands has
gone a bit funny as well I'm a focused
I've got Council wall Boys in Council
Humphries from last time so apologies if
you have yeah
thank you very much um I think there's a
mistake in the first um
the um it says um in the in the first
application it says that I am proposed
approval for the um
for the development and um it was
refusal
I think it might be just a typo typo
yeah what is the reference number sorry
counselor just for that paragraph
I'm sorry I haven't got it in front of
me but it was like thorndon
it was the chicken and
education shed was it not the metal stud
one or the horley one known
I think it was only last time we had the
holy application exactly so I'm not
quite sure
is there's a chance I've looked at the
wrong minutes I was talking about the um
the meeting where we discussed the um
Thornton chicken shed and I may have
looked at some wrong minutes but those
minutes are wrong but these um these
minutes uh yeah I believe they're right
okay we'll look into that one but I
think we've we did that one the last
time yeah so um on that basis then can
we have
um a proposer and a second a please and
you'll just have to call out because
these hands up can can we do something
with the it before we get going because
this is um a little bit distracting
um I think the only thing possible to do
chair would be to
um log out and log back in again
um but other than that I'm afraid
there's not really a solution but I
could what I can suggest is that if
members put that they want to speak in a
chat and I will create a list to send
when we get to that point
if that would be well I'll do the A to Z
which will solve that problem but um
okay well we'll keep going because we
don't want to delay any further I'm sure
everybody's waiting for the meeting to
um begin
um so can you run through um can I have
a proposal in a second of the minutes
please uh Mike Norris I'm happy to
propose thank you councilor Norris Peter
called I'm happy to Second thank you
councilor Gould
so can you do an electronic boat we'll
see if that works
thank you chair so if members could
please go to the modern.gov app and
please go into the plus sign in the top
right hand corner where the
attendance and voting tab will be shown
then you'll be guided to the list of
applications before you this morning and
a light sorry the line with the vote is
now in light blue and active
okay
thank you chair all the votes are now in
on that that is eight votes for
thank you very much indeed so
notification of petitions but um going
back to the other one as soon as I can
sign the minutes I will do so
so any petitions none received here
thank you so we'll do everything in the
order in which it sits and the first one
um is DC
1905956 land off post Mill Lane fresn
field
and so I'll now invite the case officer
Stephen Stroud to introduce the
application to the committee thank you
very much
and thank you chair good morning members
I'm uh going to attempt to share this
[Music]
so I should ask can you can you see that
yes yes well I can yeah okay good right
well good morning members
um uh members of the public uh so this
application is coming back to you today
having been deferred
on the 25th of November of last year
this is uh application at land off post
Malone fresenfield uh the application
development being for the erection of up
to
18 dwellings with Associated roads
infrastructure and open space and that's
an outline application with all matters
reserved
um just as a a small matter of
housekeeping obviously members you will
have received tabled papers yesterday so
it's important that you've had regard to
those coming into the meeting this
morning
uh by way of introduction and as I
mentioned this is a deferred item you'll
note from the paper there is a um the
officer report there is an introductory
section which just outlines uh the
status of this application in that
regard that obviously this item on the
25th of November was deferred to take
legal advice and in particular uh in
respect of the approach to decision
taking
a council opinion is provided with the
committee papers as I'm sure you are
aware of and read
um also just to be mindful members that
in the intervening period we have
received um notification of an appeal
having been lodged
by the applicant or now repellent on the
grounds of non-determination
um as far as I'm aware as of this
morning we have not received
notification that the appeal is valid or
that there is a start date so in effect
what what I'm asking or officers are
asking you to do this morning is to
agree either to follow the
recommendation and and refuse to Grant
planning permission uh this morning
today or potentially agree those
putative reasons which would go forward
in respect of the appeal itself
and that will really depend upon the
status of the application and its
currency depending on whether that
appeal has begun or not
so into the presentation and I'm mindful
members that of course that you you have
been through this in great detail
previously
um so this will be a slightly shorter
presentation but I think it will still
capture
um the key issues which are set out in
the reports
so this is an aerial view of the area in
question you can see the application
site there outlined in Orange I don't
know if you can oh you can see my mouse
good uh aligned in Orange here to the
western side of the village of fresen
fields which you can obviously see the
the form of the settlement thereabouts
and this is a slightly enlarged view of
the application site itself you can see
that it is connected to and follows from
an existing development here off post
Mill Lane
this is new streets running along here
an apology check I'll just check can you
see my mouse as I'm moving yes yes okay
it's really good so you can see new
Street here post Mill Lane leading into
the site which relates to a a generally
enclosed area of field parcel just
following on from that um that existing
development
um Steve can I just ask you just to
slowly move it because once it's whizzed
off it's difficult to find oh I'm sorry
okay on my computer it seems to be
tracking quite slowly but I apologies
that I'll go very slow
um okay so the site itself amounts to
about half a half a hectare and it is
this generally rectangular plot with the
sort of the dog leg coming round the
corner here
um post Mill Lane itself is effectively
at the moment the cold sack serving
um just over 20 dwellings
and at present the site is is obviously
Greenfield
foreign
this is the site location plan so you
can see obviously the the relationship
between the sites and nearby
developments you've also got this looser
grain running along New Street here and
the way that plots are generally sat in
in more generous plots and then you've
got this tighter development of the
existing along post Mill Lane here the
application site in red wrapping around
the existing foul Pump Station
and this area outlined in blue here this
relates to the previous application that
was refused and dismissed on appeal
uh
and now that land no longer forms part
of the proposal and is now being
promoted instead as a wildlife area so
effectively no development would take
place in this location
this is a constraints map just uh
showing again obviously the site in
context
you can see there are some listed
buildings in the vicinity
you can also see the edge of the
conservation area just here to the to
the east with the the purple shading
there is also special landscape area
across to the to the northwest
this is a photograph of the site just as
you come in off of Post Mill Lane
looking across
northwards Northeast
and a further photo obviously you've got
the uh the foul pumping station there
and it's uh it's Associated
paraphernalia
this is the indicative site layout that
was proposed or was put forward with the
application so you can see here the
general Arrangement coming around
off of Post Mill Lane here obviously
access is a reserved matter but I think
you would generally expect Reserve
matters to follow this this basic
approach
and now the indicative layout should be
viewed in the context of the drainage
strategy as well
um because that has slightly amended it
to account for the attenuation Pond that
you can see here
um I'll be honest I'm not entirely
enamored with this layout obviously
you've got the centerpiece of the
development effectively being this pump
station and what was the amenity space
now predominantly being taken up by
um this this attenuation Pond
um however I say that mindful of two
things firstly that this is this is not
a point that we've taken previously and
secondly this is of course an outline
application and I would imagine that
that reserved matters there can be some
changes minor changes to the layout that
would actually
um overcome my concerns in respect of
that particular point for example doing
something in this plot here perhaps
giving over a bit more public
open space
and maybe relocating some dwellings or a
dwelling to this location
this is the wildlife area master plan
that's been provided to indicate how
that blue lined area that I showed you
um a few moments ago on the plan could
be brought forward
um the weightiness of the this is a
benefit is something that's treated in
the officer report
on to the
um
the sort of the meet and drink of this
presentation now um the format is
effectively going to follow the
structure of the reports
um just so you're aware so it's going to
have a fairly simple format I'm going to
run through effectively the policy
context first of all and then I'm going
to take you step by step through the key
issues that are set out in the report
now on each slide what you'll see is
that you'll have some numbers in
parentheses these relate to
specific paragraphs in the report just
for reference and hopefully you can
perhaps follow both as as we go
so in respect of the policy context this
is something that's set out at the first
section of the officer reports and
obviously it's really important to
understand first and foremost what hour
or your legal Duties are in respect to
the decision to be taken
um first and foremost of course we've
got the duties under the um the
principal Act and the planning and
compulsory Purchase Act which
effectively read together require you to
um follow the development plan unless
material indications indicate otherwise
and of course as a matter of law you
must take into account material
considerations
mindful also of of various comments that
have been made in respect of Heritage
um you also have the duties of the
listed buildings act notably section 66
which relates to listed buildings and
their setting and also then section 72
which relates to conservation areas now
that particular Duty doesn't strictly
apply here because the development
application site is not within the
conservation area but I'm aware that
um it has been put to you in
representations that by virtue of the
related impacts of the development this
could affect the conservation area but
for the reason set out in the report
officers are satisfied that there would
be no harm in respect of heritage
onto the neighborhood plan obviously
there is a neighborhood plan in force
here and that is the phresic field
neighborhood development plan which was
made
um earlier last year
so it is part of the development plan
and therefore in accordance with that
section 386 Duty that I mentioned a
moment ago it is the starting point for
decision taking as a part of the
development plan
we now move on to what the most
important policies are
now this is a matter of judgment and
obviously some policies within the
development plan are going to be more
directly applicable or engaged than
others for the purposes of this
application your officers consider that
they would be fres one
press 11 fit and fresh 15 they relate to
housing provision localized flooding and
pollution transport and Highway Safety
FC 1.1 which is from the core strategy
focused review
cs1 CS2 and H7 of the local plan
obviously relating to housing and
housing in the countryside and our
spatial strategy at the district level
CS4 from the core strategy which relates
to adapting to climate change and when
the and within the context of this
application obviously having great
relevance in terms of flooding and then
T10 which is our highways policy
um now of course members um we also have
the national planning policy framework
the mppf which sets out for us the
government's planning policies for
England and how they're expected to be
applied and you would also read that
alongside the national planning practice
guidance
um both of which are material
considerations therefore you must take
them into account
uh the next point to raise is this uh um
in inverted commas the wavender baskets
um we'll get on to that again shortly
but that really
um what that encompasses here is the
fact that those most important policies
that I've just referred to standing back
looking at them and taking them in the
round they are considered to be up to
date for the purposes of the
determination of this application
and following from that the Tilted
balance and officers do not consider
that this is a tilted balance case I.E
paragraph 11d2 of the framework does not
apply
it's also important within this policy
context members to be mindful of that
previous appeal decision it is something
that is material to the decision to be
taken today and that is treated in the
officer report at those paragraphs
highlighted
um some aspects of the appeal decision
will be more relevant than others
so in respect of the key issues um there
are three and I've effectively followed
the
um the wording put forward by the
inspector in that previous appeal
decision and as I say for the purposes
of this presentation we'll take each key
issue in turn the first one relates to
the principle of development or or
indeed the spatial strategy of the
council and indeed at the local level
bearing in mind the fresenfield
neighborhood plan the second issue being
highway safety and network capacity
and the third key issue being flood risk
and drainage
so in respect of key issue one obviously
starting with the district policies
those strategic policies that are under
the wide development plan we're told
under policy cs1 the fresen field is a
primary Village which is an unfortunate
wording because I think it gives it an
elevated status when in actual fact it
is a third tier settlement which means
that it is only appropriate for limited
growth in accordance with local need
and that development we are told should
be limited to sites within settlement
boundaries or allocated sites adjacent
to such boundaries now for the purposes
of this application The Proposal is of
course outside of the settlement
boundary and is unallocated for
developments and there is no evidence of
local need that has been provided
in that respect it is uh it is not in
accordance with policy cs1 and it does
not meet any of the exceptions under
policy CS2 either
moving on to uh the fresenfield
neighborhood plan and phrase one I've
copied that policy for you there
um in its entirety
um I won't read it all out for you
um but in effect what fresda fres1 does
is is set out for you um the spatial
strategy for the neighborhood plan area
of fresenfield it does permit new
development within the newly defined
settlement boundary and it accounts for
housing policies and allocations
sufficient to meet it's identified
requirements
now considering the application
development
um against that which I'll do in a
second I'll just point out to you there
the the newly
um I should say redrawn settlement
boundary for fresen field which you can
see outlined in purple here
those two
um red
squares these are allocated sites so
those are those sites which are which
form part of phrase one and they already
benefit from planning permission the
site itself is is starred here in in
Black outside of the settlement boundary
Edge you can see here
applying phrase one
um we know that the application site is
not allocated we know that it's outside
of the settlement boundary
it is not an application that engages uh
paragraph 79 of the framework and has
set out a moment ago no housing need
assessment is provided and there is no
evidence of a local need for this
development which is obviously important
bearing in mind
um the uh the up-to-date nature of the
neighborhood plan itself which does have
an identified requirement and sets out
policies and allocations to meet that
requirements
and straightforwardly therefore the
application is in Conflict uh conflict
with phrase one
and on account of this you'll note from
the papers that officers consider that
the application thus fails to comply
with the development plan taken as a
whole
moving on to the second key issue
highway safety and network capacity it's
important to reflect on the appeal
decision because this is material as I
say
and it's important there just to reflect
on the inspectors judgment that he
exercised in respect of this matter
uh where he considers that uh
obviously the council and local
interested parties have put forward
their case
he's also considered the evidence put
forward by the uh the then appellant and
which included a transport report and
pedestrian route assessments
and the inspector was inclined to agree
with the appellant and notes that the
proposal would not have a harmful effect
on Highway and pedestrian safety within
the village
nor would there be a network a
particular Network issue so this is not
um in the terms of the mppf for power
109 case
um so this leaves us in a situation
where we have obviously quite an
important uh Direction here from a
planning inspector
uh and this leads us to obviously the
currency of this particular application
I am going to run you through the
details again because while
um obviously officers have taken into
account that appeal decision it is
important for members to nevertheless
just consider this matter afresh
so this is a an exploded view of
fresenfield in particular the western
side and you've got the application site
here obviously that pumping station a
post Mill Lane which takes you down to
New Street and this would effectively be
the key route for pedestrians
um as future occupiers of the
development as they move eastwards to
benefit from the services and Facilities
within the village
this is a plan that's taken from
the applicants pedestrian route
assessment which just highlights the
relationship of the site to those
services and Facilities
I'm just going to run you through a
number of slides now which just show the
um the the route of travel for
pedestrians to reach each one of those
services
so you see here in respect to the
medical center you would follow the
footpath along post Mill Lane come down
onto New Street and then come out on a
round to reach the practice
this is how you would reach the the
primary school in all likelihood you
would come down and you come on to
Priory Road and you'd make your way down
here through sandcroft way and proceed
through a field gate to then get across
to the school
uh the village shop being here
and this is the route to the public
houses in the village you'll note here
this this cut through that you can see
um this was this is available as a cut
through between houses
um
to get onto
um the B triple one six laxfield road
going northwards
um that would enable pedestrians to
avoid going around Jubilee corner
and this is the route to the sports and
social club here which does require you
to navigate uh Jubilee corner but I'll
show that in a bit more detail shortly
I'm gonna take you on a very brief
photographic walking tour now just to
show you um the route I appreciate you
will have been through this with the
case officer previously so I will move
it into cancer this is the site access
obviously going into post Mill Lane here
in the existing development
this is looking out from the access onto
new streets you can see the dropped
curbs here
foreign
this is looking eastwards along new
street from the Bell mouth
and then this is looking West you can
see the access here and you can see the
dropped curbs
this is Priory road that I showed you a
moment ago this would be the the most
likely route for for people to get to
the school the primary school what you
will note is that this is quite tight on
this corner here which does restrict
visibility
now moving eastwards along new streets
and obviously you'll note the car there
that's parked on the on the footpath
is from the same position looking back
to the West
we're now moving further along the east
again you can see there are subtle bends
along the road members
and then back to the west and you can
see that that car
further along new street again East
and west
East again now here you'll you'll note
this particular Bend which restricts
visibility
um for for pedestrians who who might be
traveling on the southern side of new
streets
and that's further along again
um eastwards
and the same position looking back to
the West
and this is the Village Store here you
can see to the right of the of the
screenshot so again looking East here
and obviously it's important to
recognize members of course along the
majority of this stretch we've just
traversed there are no no foot ways so
you would be traveling in in the highway
and looking West
and this is Jubilee Corner approached
from the East so you can see in this
area here this is New Street
and this is the footway then that we're
on the southern side of New Street
that's leading around the corner onto
stradbroke Road and across the junction
onto the B triple one six
now there has been a recorded incidents
uh incident in this location a slight
incident
um but it was as I understand it put
down to drive error rather than any
particular design flaw with the junction
itself
and this is an exploded view which shows
you that corner again
um and this is the cut flip cut through
that I mentioned earlier that would
enable pedestrians to avoid this Bend
and and keep on a foot path then to
travel up to the public houses
and this is where the cut through comes
out to and then you can see there's that
footway that leads up
this is a crossing point
um to get onto the other side of the
road and the footway leading this way
and obviously the the Fox and Goose
Public House and what you will notice
again here visibility is rather poor
um
at this at this particular Point
um where this vegetation appears to have
overgrown into the public Highway
and this is a another enlarged view just
showing the the Jubilee Corner again
um you've got this central island
splitter here and
in respect of how uh
between stradbrick road and laxfield
road but also it's a feature that
pedestrians would be expected to
navigate in order to make their way to
the sports and social club
so it's been remarked before that this
particular Bend does narrow in terms of
footway and what people tend to do is
come around the corner and then drop
down and come across this splitter and
then make their way onto the verge
so in respect of the applicant's
transport statement
um it finds a few things and firstly
that it considers that having undertaken
a traffic count
movements along new streets
um are relatively low with low speeds
there's a mean speed of 24.5 miles per
hour
of course the trip generation from this
particular development as well bearing
in mind it's it's Quantum a scale of 18
units it's going to be relatively low
and you also have the crash map data
that's been referred to before which
shows a a low incidence rate really and
over the last 20 years there are three
slight incidents that have been recorded
now again these are recorded incidents
so that's not to say that there are some
things that occur that are that go
unreported and in that respect um safes
pedestrian survey is quite important
because clearly there is anecdotal
evidence
um that there is a real problem in terms
of Highway Safety
however what the applicant has done is
undertake a pedestrian route assessment
in accordance with rosper guidance and
they have found that some sections or
routes are potentially unsafe
which requires mitigation in order to be
classed as non-hazardous
now those three there are three
proposals that they've put forward in
order to overcome that issue and which
have been set out in their pedestrian
route assessment on their planning
statement the first of which
is an adjustment of the junction radius
and with Associated Footwear widening at
the junction of New Street and Priory
Road
that's that's the route to school that I
showed you earlier where it gets quite
narrow around the bend
relocating that dropped curb opposite
the Fox and Goose Pub in the event that
the vegetation can't be cleared
and then also the promotion of a tro on
New Street to lower speeds to 20 miles
per hour
and this slide just on the left here
you'll see this is how the proposal
would look in respect to that Priory
Road Junction and so you see that
effectively the Footwear has been been
widered the junction narrowed
um with an amended crossing here and
then you've got these Gateway points
with signage um entering into the 20
mile per hour Zone
effectively where you you are faced with
that um Highway where it has no
um
footways
and this is just showing the the extent
of that that 20 mile an hour route
so in respect of the highway safety
issues
um I think as I I've pointed out earlier
it's important to recognize that
the inspector has had regard to this
previously or an inspector has in terms
of that previous appeal and found no
harm
uh and obviously it was the council's
case at that time that there would be a
highway safety issue that was not not
capable of being mitigated
um the inspector disagreed
um to my mind there's been no particular
change of circumstances that would
warrant us to to change
um or depart from that guidance and
we're now obviously mindful that the
highway Authority does not object either
so on that basis officers do conclude
that there is an acceptable impact with
regard to safety and there would be no
severe impact on the local network but
that is of course members subject to
securing the improvements that have been
identified by the applicants
um and and this is something that
obviously we would deal with through the
appeals process to ensure that
conditions are suitably worded and with
acceptable trigger points
in terms of the final key issue this is
flood risk and drainage and and this is
something that relates to uh an issue
that is well known and has been well
rehearsed
uh it is again an issue that has been
dealt with by an inspector as part of
the previous appeal
where on account of the fact that the um
anglian water
as the responsible body for the foul
Network raises no objections
uh the inspector found it very difficult
to find harm in that respect bearing in
mind that it is considered that there is
capacity with this within the system
itself to take the foul flows associated
with the proposed developments
these are just some photographs to
highlight of course members that this is
a very real issue a live issue in the
village itself
um has no doubt local parties will will
inform you
um shortly within the public speaking
slots
and there are localized flooding issues
within the village this is identified
within the neighborhood plan as you can
see these highlighted areas here we also
know in terms of localized localized
flood riskist extent from the county
councilors the lead local flood
Authority that you have a number of
reported issues in the village
you also have them mapped out here the
um the one in 30 and the one in 100
risk events
obviously the application site is
outside of those areas at the other end
of post Mill Lane but of course members
in policy terms what we're looking for
here is to ensure that because this is a
development that would increase surface
water runoff and it's got to deal with
that in such a way that it is not going
to increase the risk of flooding
elsewhere
so in that respect this um this
represents the applicant's drainage
strategy
um I will explain it
um hopefully you can see where my mouse
is you've got these orange this Orange
Point here
and the Orange Lines this relates to the
existing foul Network and you can see
that the existing dwellings are feeding
into that and it comes into the pump
station here
in respect of the new development we've
got these purple dots and lines
illustrating the localized Network for
this development where the foul would
come in and down and connect and go into
that pump station
in terms of surface water this is dealt
with in a separate Manner and this is
what these blue dark blue dotted lines
are here can you just slow down with
your mouse oh sorry we're having
difficulty keeping up with you as you're
showing us please okay so the blue
dotted lines here you can see where the
surface water is
connected
and moved
and it comes down
into the attenuation
pond
where it will be held and then at a
controlled rate
it will come out and it will flow
northwards and join the existing
Watercourse which is this light blue
so there are see two particular drainage
points here you've got foul and you have
surface water and they are dealt with in
separate ways foul goes into the pump
station which is the anglian water
assets and that is the asset that we're
told by angling water has capacity to
deal with the foul flows from this
development
in order to ex not exacerbate pressure
on that surface water will not enter The
Pump Station it's on a separate Network
localized to the developments
where it will flow into the attenuation
Pond and then be released
into the existing Watercourse here at
the ditch Network to the north
and this shows the direction of the
outfall so where I showed you earlier it
will be coming into the the ditch here
it then runs in a Westerly Direction and
then comes out and flows away from the
village
so in respect of that third key issue we
have no objection from the lead local
flood Authority
we don't have an objection from anglian
water and we're told that the network
has capacity to deal with the foul flows
to arise from this development just to
stress again no surface water will be
entering the pump station or foul
network from this development
and to reiterate again there is
considered to be capacity in the foul
Network for the flows
foreign
members on the evidence available at
this time it's not considered that there
is a clear link between the proposed
development we have here and an
increased risk of flooding elsewhere in
the village
and in accordance with the findings of
the previous inspector it's not
considered that there is
um a a reasonable reason for refusal in
respect to this key issue
obviously scheme benefits these are
material considerations so again they
need to be factored into account and
principally they relate to Market and
affordable housing and which will see a
mainly a social and economic benefit
construction benefits there are some
Highway improvements albeit they are of
course required in order to make the
development acceptable in planning terms
and then you have the wildlife area
now in terms of the planning balance
um just taking this through in a very
rudimentary Way section 386
um that's that Duty which requires you
to start with the development plan and
follow it unless material considerations
indicate otherwise and that's something
that's reiterated under paragraph 12 of
the framework
um now we know from key issue one that
there is a failure to record the
development plan as a whole
so there is a direction to refuse
planning permission and that's step one
of the 386 balance
now on the other side of that we've got
to factor in those other material
considerations
that's step two
so as I stated earlier in the policy
context slide this is not a tilted
balance case
because we have a five-year land Supply
we've passed the most recent housing
delivery test
and that basket of policy is most
important for the determination of this
application are up to date
and we also consider that the
application are on account of that that
harm to the plan-led system it fails to
record with the mppf as a whole too so
those other material considerations
don't actually depart from the direction
to refuse if anything they support it
and then lastly we've got the scheme
benefits which are benefits and they do
need to be weighed in and they of course
weigh against that direction to Grant
planning permission
so if you imagine uh
balance a set of scales
um I've drawn them as flat in this case
or straight this is your ordinary
planning balance because this is not a
tilted balance case
and then when you put the inputs in
obviously we see that the harm as it
were
decisively outweighs the benefits which
then leads us to the recommendation that
you've got before us members and that is
that the fresenfield neighborhood
development plan provides a
comprehensive strategy for growth which
positively plans for development to meet
its identified needs the fndp is
recently made and in relation to new
housing identifies where sustainable
Housing Development should and should
not go the proposed development of up to
18 dwellings outside of the settlement
boundary in the countryside and without
a justifiable need fails to record with
policy phrase one
it fails to record a policy cs1 CS2 and
H7 an intern policy FC 1.12
straightforwardly the proposed
development is inimical to the spatial
strategy of an up-to-date development
plan it conflicts with the development
plan as a whole for this reason it
doesn't represent sustainable
development and it is contrary to the
nppf
so members are going back to that
balance where the development conflicts
with the development plan taken as a
whole and there are no other material
considerations which indicate that the
decision should be taken other than in
accordance with the plan the
recommendation is to refuse to Grant
planning permission in accordance with
items one two and three of the
recommendation in your papers
thank you chair
thank you
um
could you turn off your video
Mrs balham please could you turn off the
video
that's better thank you
sorry about that
um before I go to members can I just say
Stephen that was a very very clear
up-to-date presentation and there was a
lot more information in there for
members to consider
um particularly with the um photographs
and Graphics so from my point of view
thank you very much for that
now I have to apologize I don't know if
these are old hands hands coming up so
can I ask Robert to introduce each
counselor if they have a question for
clarity please
okay
I don't see any hands up so I'm not
would anybody uh if their hands up
aren't working is there anybody that
wishes to question those
if not we can move on
thank you very much committee so um
if we know
chairman is it is it is it appropriate
for me to just add add a point here yes
indeed yes yes if you wish that would be
helpful yes
unconscious members that we are in a
situation where you have council's
advice uh in your agenda bundle at the
back of the console T papers we're not a
console t
and I think before debate proceeds I
think it's useful just for myself to
reflect on the fact that
um
we have taken legal advice given the uh
debate at the last meeting and it's
important to remember that this question
of the national planning policy
framework in paragraph 11 need to be
seen in context and you have quite a lot
of legal advice before you which can be
quite confusing so I wanted just to take
take a moment to draw breath around that
uh we hear a lot in committee about the
nppf and paragraph 11d and that says
quite literally for decision taking
advice to us is that where there are no
relevant development plan policies or
the policies which are most important
for determining the application are out
of date we should be granting Planning
Commission so that's what paragraph 11d
of the nppf tells us
but the situation here is that there are
relevant development plan policies and
they are policies which are most
important for determining the
application and so my advice to you this
morning is that they can be considered
to be up-to-date as Stephen has said
drawing as they do on an up-to-date
neighborhood plan which itself has
regard to the National planning policy
framework
so for all of the debate that has gone
on regarding the nppf and paragraph 11d
it is perhaps wise to reflect that it
doesn't strictly apply to the
circumstances before us this morning
and in the present circumstances this
morning
um we do have uh up-to-date policies and
these can include our own development
plan
because the neighborhood plan has made
provision to meet local housing need in
this neighborhood plan area and
therefore in this neighborhood plan area
it's appropriate for us to control other
sporadic proposals under our strategic
policies hand in glove with the
neighborhood plan uh assuming of course
that material considerations don't
persuade us otherwise
so in the decision before you today both
the neighborhood plan and the core
strategy and local plan policies that
Stephen has identified are the
development plan uh they work together
and officers consider that they are up
to date for the purposes of the decision
this morning
and with that in mind uh the expectation
in the statute section 38 sex is that
the council will make the decision in
accordance with the plan unless there
are material considerations that
indicate otherwise
so we can be confident we will be right
if there are no material considerations
to indicate otherwise
the following the plan LED approach is
appropriate and is what is required of
us under the statute they are accepting
that there is quite a lot of legal
advice now available to you I don't wish
to treat this too simplistically but
what council has probably reminded us is
actually about first principles and we
don't actually have to make this more
complicated than it really is now
chairman I'll leave it there and happy
to answer questions as we go through
debate
thank you
so if we now move on thank you for that
Philip um we move on to the public
speakers and Robert if you would concur
we now have the parish council is that
correct for our first speaker
good morning to you good morning chair
and counselors
um thank you for taking some time just
to listen to a very brief statement that
I'm going to make
the parish council is obviously very
pleased with the advice received from
Council regarding the waiting of the
neighborhood development plan we're also
very pleased with the subsequent officer
report
it was such a Pity your legal services
did not research the matter more
thoroughly before going to council much
of that case law and arguments is
readily available online
that said we would urge the committee to
take the recommendation from the
extremely well written logical planning
officer report and refused the
application for the 18 houses on post
Mill you've heard all our arguments
before and those arguments stand
but we would like to just put on record
we still disagree with the highways
assessment about Road Safety on New
Street
and we continue to question anglian
Waters assessment of the sewage drainage
not being affected by additional housing
thank you for your time
thank you very much that was very
succinct thank you very much indeed now
do members have any questions
for Diane Warren
no thank you very much indeed so if
you'd like to turn your video off and
watch the rest of the debate thank you
and now Robert would I concur that it is
now the applicant who wishes to speak
to speak next
right okay I'm very happy with that I
told you I'd got people out of order so
I do apologize Mr Castro
um your turn now thank you
good morning I'm John Castro and I'm
representing safe
we oppose the development strongly and
we strongly support the LPA which after
legal advice agrees with the made recent
well-supported highly praised NDP is of
overriding importance
the applicator this application fails
the NDP it's not in the designated
Development Area and it's outside the
settlement boundary
if approved it overshoots the accepted
house numbers significantly and the plan
itself still has 15 years to run
I will focus today on sustainability
covered in press 3 of the NDP
the primary school is now in capacity if
the surgery is stressed and this car
park is often full necessitating
dangerous on-street parking
it's difficult to recruit medical staff
in Suffolk there's no secondary
education and very few jobs
employment requires travel there's no
public transport in our village our
carbon footprint is therefore High
these difficulties will increase by
Building 54 approved houses in the
village and 80 approved in waybred
Gooding in post bill would worsen the
situation
hi boys as you've heard was dismissed by
the inspector because of the low
incidence of accidents but many as
you've heard go unreported
much has changed since his report the
developments mentioned above will come
on stream increasing traffic
we've no cycle routes or facilities for
Wheelchairs and the disabled in fact
non-motorized movement in pressing field
is frankly dangerous
development in post Mill means more
traffic
in January 2020 safe commissioned a road
safety study with 104 respondents and 84
percent of them felt unsafe when walking
in dressing field due to poor visibility
and speed
the sewage system is worse with 18
incidents in the last two and a half
years with sewage in the roads Pathways
and people's Gardens each episode lasts
between 4 and 27 hours and there have
been 13
episodes since the inspector's report
angling water assessment is theoretical
it's based on Drive flow reality is
different surface or water occupies part
of the system so the capacity for fell
water decreases
surface water from post Mill is not the
issue but increased foul is it will put
more strain on the sewer which cannot
cope and has finite capacity
the frequency of sewage egress will
increase even the CEO Evangeline water
says that at times his system is
overwhelmed
please refuse this application on the
grounds that it does not comply with the
NDP there are infrastructure deficits
resulting in significant and Mr Castro
you are up on your three minutes could
you conclude please
it specifically contravenes policy at
free
well done
thank you very much indeed now then
we'll go to members and ask if there are
any questions for you members any
questions
can you see any Robert no
thank you Mr Castro and I would like to
add we have read all the additional late
papers which are extremely thorough and
consistent I have to say so thank you
for that and I'm sure all our members
have read all the late papers that have
come in as well as the current papers so
thank you
so um now if we can move on um Robert
who would you suggest we talk to next
yes indeed and Mr Davidson if you would
like to have three minutes please
good morning everyone my name is Charlie
Davidson I was born and raised at the
end of post Mill Lane uh where my
parents still live uh my grandmother
also lives at the end of personal Lane
I'm only telling you that so you're
aware we're not
um a faceless developed we are members
of the community we were approached by
mid-suffolk
to develop this site because they
recognized that it was an appropriate
place to build what feels like many
years ago now during that time we have
not faced any statutory consultee
objection that we don't believe we've
been able to overcome but we which
sounds like a good thing but we found
ourselves in an awkward position where
we have uh objectives naturally
objecting and we're facing issues that
we would love to install sewage
treatment on the site we would love to
have provided greater attenuation but
the consultee so there is no need and
therefore our hands are tied on the
issue elsewhere in the village there's
been 18 houses allocated at
um
School Lane 28 Red House Farm the parish
council recently have approved or
recommended approval to adjust the 18
houses on School Lane to 12. this means
there's 40 houses effectively and this
will be coming before you soon we're
we're proposing 18 houses on post Mill
Lane which brings us to 58 that's below
the 60 of the NDP
also the boundaries for the Development
Area were drawn after the two allocated
sites were already approved for outline
commission so naturally an NDP would put
our site outside of the allocation Zone
but what this means is this being the
smallest and most deliverable site in in
the village but if this is refused every
other house built in the next 15 years
in frozen field will be won through
windfall and as I'm sure you're aware
with windfall comes no affordable
housing
said that frozen food is in dire need of
affordable housing if this is refused
there will be no windfall for 15 years
in frozen field and what is already very
expensive Village to live
you as you realize obviously we are
looking to go to appeal and you are
deliberating this and
um we hope that you'll recognize that
the consulties the experts uh the
district council experts do not have
objections with this application and
until very recently the case officers
were supporting this and we hope that
you will come to the conclusion that
this is an application that should have
been improved and if you have any
questions please do ask I'm happy to
help
um but thank you for your time
thank you very much and indeed members
are there any questions
for Mr Davidson at all Robert can you
see anybody that have any questions
there
no
um right thank you very much for your
time
sorry I'm seeing a hand up I can't see
who it is I think it's councilor
Stringer sorry to interrupt I can see
right I'm sorry I just can't see it
counselor Stringer your question please
thank you thank you it's it's actually
possibly a question of an officer about
a statement about if there will be no
further opportunity for 15 years for a
new development outside of the
fresenfield neighborhood plan boundary
can I just clarify whether the
neighborhood plan has a review process
built into it because it's my
understanding that all neighborhood
plans should
yeah that wouldn't be for Mr Davidson
but quite rightly for the officer um
councilor Stringer thank you Mr Davidson
I think um you may uh switch off and um
could an officer just answer councilor
stringer's question if you would please
uh
oh he's got oh excited
no no no no after you Stephen well I was
really going to it it really depends
upon the circumstances of the particular
neighborhood plan in question but
strictly speaking I think the the need
to have uh a continual um hand on the
tiller shall we say um also comes
through paragraph 14 of the framework
which obviously only gives you in the
event that there's a tilted balance case
a two-year window to take advantage of
its direction so there is a need to keep
an eye on
um you know your policies and how things
are moving on the ground but at this
particular point in time you have
um based on the evidence that has
supported the the plan you have um
phrase one which says it is seeking to
meet a need of 60 dwellings that's been
accepted that's also the direction of
travel of the emerging joint local plan
so there is nothing on the ground at the
moment to indicate that this plan would
require any sort of review in the
immediate future and I think that's
probably the the best way that I can
answer at this point in time because
policies can become out of date as a
matter of judgment very quickly and and
without warning it really depends upon
um how you treat them in terms of for
example their consistency with the
framework or as events are changing
um on a national or localized basis so
that's a bit of a fudge of an answer for
you there Council Australia but it's
it's not one I can answer with with a
particular
um dffinity
if I can just add to what Stephen has
said Jim I mean there is a current
consultation on the nppf underway it is
highly likely given the statements made
by government that they will recast the
nppf and it would be beyond the wit of
an officer or indeed I suspect a
counselor to predict what the future
policy on neighborhood plans their
status and and their review will be The
Prudent thing will be for the parish to
review it the question of whether the
only growth that will come through will
be through uh windfall sites that is a
presumption it's not a presumption we as
officers would make it it is it is a a
possibility but the reality is that we
are speculating on a future which has
particularly uncertainties and I would
suggest that what we should focus on is
the decision on this application on its
merits today
yes thank you for that um Philip I was
going to mention that the mppf is up for
review and to be fair it was a statement
made by the applicant um but I think
it's aired um everything that needed to
be said now is there anyone else who
wish to
speak on that matter so we now move on
I think we're quite clear to move on to
our Ward member is that your view of it
Robert
councilor hattingham thank you
thank you as the previous committee
meeting was so recent I feel there's no
need to repeat mine and the village is
concerned regarding this application the
fact that the recommendation is now for
refusal I can agree wholeheartedly with
the officer's advice and leave it to the
committee to decide how to proceed and I
would just like to say thank you for
your time spent reading the numerous
emails and taking an interest in our
village but what I would like to say is
um Stevens um
facts and figures on and the Crash mats
talking about one incident on Jubilee
corner it's just um like well he said
him himself it's only the reported
instance and I would like to say that in
my Reckoning there's probably at least
one a year but but people don't see the
need to to report it why would you do
and you know but that friends I would
say is the place like you say almost
yearly if not every five years and my
sister lives along um or has a house
along New Street and she's had her wall
hit you know numerous times anyway thank
you for listening
thank you do members have any questions
for councilor hardingham
Robert oh nobody doing that thank you
very much indeed
right
we now aren't a debate so I think in our
fashion and because of this hands-up
problem
um may we go please
um doing the uh we'll still do A to Z
because that's what my list says so
councilor Caston would you like to speak
first please
thank you very much Madam chairman
um I'll put this in simple terms
nothing's changed for me here still the
same issues that we um talked about in
the last meeting we've got a bit more um
legal Clarity on those which was a
really important process that I think we
needed to take the um we've got a um
primary Village here that's appropriate
for limited growth but with the the big
thing about this is this fresn feel
neighborhood plan is a solid and
up-to-date document and it's allocated
um most of the local need of the housing
it's um
it's um outside this developments
outside of the settlement boundary which
is policy as well it's um we're
balancing harm against need here and um
the need is low the um then there's
several aspects of harm I'm I'm less
concerned about highways um but I think
this does carry weight considering the
um limited weight of the local need that
we're considering here now this Anglia
Waters situation they've um they've said
there's no issue where they've they've
measured the foul water
um I don't think
I dispute this I don't think this is
correct I think there's solid evidence
that there is
um issues uh with overflowing sewers and
it's polluting the um surrounding area
and as a Committee Member
I think we've we've got a um
we we consider evidence as a Committee
Member we look at evidence
um I think I can wholeheartedly dispute
that evidence that's been put in front
of me and in the interests of community
need and that this um and um doing
things right I think I would continue to
pursue that there is a sewage problem
there and it is um there's no capacity
in that um in that system but um yeah
I'll quite happily listen to what other
members think about that because
obviously we do we have a um a statement
that says there's no issue there but I I
definitely dispute that thank you
thank you councilor Kirsten I think what
we've got to be mindful of is the
evidence that has been presented to us
and legal evidence and that
um the planning officer has put his
recommendations forward uh on the basis
of what we can fully defend
um so I think we need to be mindful of
that moving forward but it doesn't
dispel the problems that the village has
be they historically or we don't want it
to get worse so we need to be mindful of
all those things so moving forward may
we have councilor Gould please thank you
thank you thank you very much chair and
I I just wanted to start by echoing your
own comments about uh the the quality of
this report the quality and the clarity
of this report uh which I think has been
immensely helpful
um in setting out and setting out the
issues and actually I find I would ask
that is think about whether the things
within the the approach to this report
and the way it's set out that might be
applied uh to other applications because
I have found it helpful
one area in which I find it particularly
helpful is in terms of understanding uh
the issue about put when policies can be
considered uh up to date or on or not
the other thing I I just wanted to make
a brief reference to in in council's
opinion where he quotes
um bonus hell of of Richmond often we
sit in these committees uh and we're
we're we're
sensitive to the needs of communities
but we're often advised about the
restraints and constraints that we face
in terms of planning regulations and so
on and and actually trying to to realize
the Democratic purpose that we have in
that situation is tricky and and I'd
like particularly if you can indulge me
just a moment a bonus hell's comment
that in this country planning decisions
are taken by a democratically elected
councilors responsible to and sensitive
to the concerns of their local local
communities now often actually the
planning regulation be the mppf or or
whatever uh makes that a difficult job
I'm grateful here that the the legal
advice the clarity of the
um the officer report
makes me feel I'm in a position where uh
I can take I can I can put forward a
proposal or take a decision that I want
to take and knowing that it fits within
within the planning the planning rules
uh and for me I've come to like
um uh councilor customers just saying
about the uh the the flooding
and I said Mr was it Dr Castro was
saying about the difference between
Theory and reality
um that remains an issue for me because
I know in frestonfield we have a bit of
the same issue in I as well where in
theory the system is okay but the
reality is you still get foul water in
in the road and so on and it's a disso
with highways considerations where it
may not meet thresholds to cause concern
but there is a reality that you know
there is a danger and a risk there and
things go unreported uh so I'm not sure
what we do about this report hasn't
quite cracked that one but in terms of
the other issues I I think it's been
immensely helpful uh and uh you know
applaud the work of officers yeah in
this case thank you
thank you councilor Gould and now
councilor Humphries please
I'm sure thank you um I'd like to concur
with councilor gold really on the uh
production by the officer I thought it
was excellent
um and very very clear and I love the
use of the scales that actually did
quite a lot to um to sort of
um reason this out for me so it's so
well done on that maybe that model could
be taken forward in the future
um let's come back to the report itself
the I understand the comments on the
drainage I understand the comments on
the highways from Mrs Warn and also from
councilor Caston
um however
um
you've got to go back to the report and
understand it properly that the report
itself is probably robust enough in its
recommendations refusals without needing
to add the issues of the drainage and
also the highways especially when you
consider that there are reports within
the report from the inspector from
highways from anglian water that
actually argue against it and and I do
get the point from the people that live
in fresenfield who live it I totally
understand that but we've got to go back
to what's in the report as well and give
it some balance
uh therefore I do think there's enough
in the recommendations for refusal on
this anyway
um the freshing field uh neighborhood
plan is excellent and in fact in the
recommendations it sums it up the
Freshman field neighborhood development
plan provides a comprehensive strategy
for growth which positively plans for
development to meet its identified needs
excellent and and obviously it will be
up for review
I've looked at this I'll listen to the
the last meeting we had nothing's
changed in my opinion uh to be honest
with you the the water and drainage
I'd I'd probably move away from that
because an excuse the point it sort of
muddies the water a little bit when
there's enough here to point out why
this shouldn't shouldn't go ahead
um I'm not sure that I'm well I think I
will be supporting recommendation for uh
for refusal on this but I'll listen to
if it comes to this first thank you
thank you councilor Humphries councilor
Mellon
yeah thank you chair
um in the interests of not prolonging
debate
um I'll just say briefly
um back in November I seconded a
proposal for refusal which was
um subsequently withdrawn
um but I was minded to vote for refusal
back in November and and then we we
deferred to seek clarification and I
think we have that clarification now I
welcome the the legal papers and I
welcome council's opinion and the
details in the officer's report
it does seem that we are moving from uh
in this case a developer-led approach
to a plan-led approach and I welcome
that and
um I am very minded to support the
officers recommendation thank you
thank you very much councilor Mellon and
now we moved to councilor Norris
oh thank you madam chair
um I don't wish also to repeat
everything that's been said uh I have
questions regarding the flooding and the
highways issues but that apart I think
that's all been covered I think as it
has been said the sufficient uh in the
report which is very comprehensive
actually uh to justify refusalem
um I did vote against approval of the
application when it came before
committee previously and as far as I'm
concerned nothing much has changed
actually it's not a sustainable location
uh local bus service has been withdrawn
it requires the use of a car to get
anywhere uh is the profession girls
classified and there are three tier
sorry tier three rating I.E limited
growth
should only respond to local need
there's no evidence of need being
required audits outside settlement
boundary not allocated within the
Freshman field neighborhood plan doesn't
Accord with the development plan as a
whole so those those reasons in
themselves I think are more than
sufficient to justify refusalem and I
wholeheartedly agree with the
recommendation to refers so thank you
for that
thank you councilor Norris counselor
Stringer
thank you chair I'll I'll try not to
repeat anything that's been said before
uh just wanted a make a couple of points
uh first of all I will get the sewage
out the way we can uh we often play this
little game where locals know that any
effect on rainwater or sewage will
exacerbate an existing problem the
problem we have we don't have the
policies to address that unless any of
the uh huge stakeholders in this do
object which they really don't because
actually they have as the Americans call
it skin in the game Anglia water will be
charging quite a lot of people in
dressing field for putting their rain
water into the sewage uh therefore if it
all goes wrong they should be putting it
right but as we find often they don't uh
which is why they never complain they
rarely complain when it comes to a
planning application because it would
pull apart their regime for for charging
for their service uh but of course with
this particular one we have a made
neighborhood plan that we now have
very good sound legal advice as to how
it should stack up when we balance all
planning decisions all planning
decisions we should have the picture of
those scales in our head where we put
certain policies with different weights
in different parts of the scale that's
nothing new that that's exactly how we
should be looking at planning
applications and of course we've got
that legal advice that now shows us that
an up-to-date very well put together
neighborhood plan like pressing fields
and I congratulate all the volunteers
for their neighborhood plan should be
given full weight and that that count
sales opinion goes all the way through
that citing case law after case law
where it's been upheld by the government
of various inspectors where you should
be giving it full weight
also it is not true that we've got a if
we don't approve this application today
then that's the end of it for 15 years
it isn't 8.6 in the neighborhood plan it
says it will be reviewed at least every
five years so if those sites that are
currently allocated in the fresn field
neighborhood plan failed to deliver the
housing numbers required they have the
ability to review that within five years
and if they wish they could publicly
consult and put this site into the
neighborhood plan at a review and it
could come forward within five years if
that went through a referendum so
frankly I think we've had Clarity on
where the neighborhood plan sits and I
congratulate that and and frankly I will
be 100 supporting the freshing field
neighborhood plan it also does have a
policy in there fresh 11 about foul
water and sewage where it says that any
new development shouldn't make any part
of that worse than it already is which
goes beyond where Anglia water Dare To
Tread thank you chair
thank you councilor Stringer Council of
War boys please
uh thank you chair
yes I think I'd like to
acknowledge the amount of efforts that's
gone into the um
further evidence for this on this
application and the quality of Officer
Stroud's report which has really
clarified a lot of the situ the
situation
um
I I have a mind to to sort of
support the
recommendation by the officers to refuse
this application
um
that I would like to acknowledge the
terrific amount of workers that's gone
into it uh in particular getting our
policies up to date
uh the community on its neighborhood
plan
and and also the development offices on
our emerging local plan
I I do
wish to sort of I hope it's going to be
recorded by support for the parish
council with regard to the
um
reports from the consultees
um this application has highlighted
um
uh issues with pedestrian safety I
believe Sam Harvey's is present so
hopefully this will be noted by Suffolk
highways and that though this
application maybe lost some improvements
could and should be made
I think anglian water uh there's a
special mention it has in effect washed
its hands of the problem uh there will
be further development in frezing field
uh and the sewage problem will be
exacerbated by
further development I think now that our
local flood Authority Suffolk County
Council is actually flush with funds
it's going to be able to deal with this
um problem in the future
uh thank you
thank you Council of all boys
um and again I don't wish to repeat
everything but I too have been involved
in
um sort of looking how this case has
developed and moved forward
with a great deal of involvement I do
think it was important that we had
clarification from the legal council to
secure mid-suffolk District council's
position that we are all making the
right decisions I already thanked the
officer for his report I do think we
need to
um be mindful of the community's
problems with the sewage and the
highways but as we've all heard about
that
um that has a
other professionals responses to that I
would like to look at the recommendation
on page 37 and
um as well as the neighborhood plan the
first statement I think we need to
congratulate everybody there that we've
got a little bit more meat on the bones
rather than just saying the neighborhood
plan was the defensible issue and I
think it's been laid out very clearly
there and that we um probably ought to
get the officer to read it out so that
the public can hear everything as well
that we're delegating the chief planning
officer should I have a proposal from
the floor and also to endorse the
recommendation that should an appeal be
forthcoming that we request that it is a
borrow the public inquiry which is all
in the papers
um so again not wishing to prolong
everything
um I think we're all on the same page
here
um so if nobody wants to speak a second
time can I have a proposer and a
secondary thank you
I was going to propose but I I think In
fairness I might have been uh third in
line there I think yeah
I don't care thank you chair uh not
wishing to have Deja Vu happening uh but
uh gladly uh uh move refusal of this
application based on the list of
policies put out there by our officers
backed up with that legal opinion I
think that's a very sound refusal
although I personally would have liked
to see more reasons we understand why
those reasons can't be in there in terms
of we don't have a console T that will
back them up with the with the refusal
however annoying that is I'd also
congratulate the officers for actually
having a proposal which had me
scrambling to a dictionary to look up
the meaning of a word and that word was
inimicable which means obstruct or
hostile too which I I think they're
actually adequately describes if we were
to approve this development against as
it were the neighborhood plan what would
what would what would happen so I
congratulate our officers for a very
comprehensive refusal I congratulate us
for actually getting sound legal advice
and I thank the parish and the
volunteers for all the work they've done
on their neighborhood plan uh and that's
all I've got to say thank you chair
thank you and the secondary are you
going to do that councilor Mellon I
don't mind you that's it uh yes happy to
second that and agree with what council
Stringer has said Thank you thank you
very much
um well um that's being presented up
onto our voting system
um would either the planning officer or
Philip like to just run through it so
that the public can hear what were
um recommending a reviews along please
Gemini I'll let Stephen speak for
himself but I would just point out that
assuming there is a
um an appeal position to defend in due
course and assuming that the planning
inspector
uh proceed with that
um we obviously will expect to work with
the community uh in defense of that
appeal I mean clearly their concerns and
their grounds of appeal may not be ours
but there is no reason why uh we should
not uh work together to present a
coherent case because I'm sure an
inspector will wish to be uh to wish
wish to see that and understand uh both
the uh the the the the surface water
drainage issues and the highways issues
and clearly uh you know there is
evidence to be presented there thank you
chairman I'll hand over to Stephen to
talk through his recommendation thank
you very much and Robert will be typing
as we speak so Stephen if you'd just
like to run through it so members of the
public can hear as well thank you yes of
course
um I'll read the recommendation in its
entirety thank you
first item being that members resolve to
refuse planning permission or in the
event that the appeal has begun agree
putative reasons for refusal for the
following reasons
build neighborhood development plan or
fndp provides a comprehensive strategy
for growth which positively plans for
development to meet its identified needs
the fndp is recently made and in
relation to new housing identifies where
sustainable Housing Development should
and should not go the proposed
development of up to 18 dwellings
outside of the settlement boundary in
the countryside and without a
justifiable need
fails to record a policy phrase one of
the fndp it fails to record with policy
cs1 CS2 and H7 and in turn policy FC 1.1
straightforwardly the proposed
development is inimical to the spatial
strategy of an up-to-date development
plan it conflicts with the development
plan as a whole for this reason alone it
does not represent sustainable
development and is contrary to the mppf
the development conflicts with the
development plan when taken as a whole
and there were no material
considerations which indicate that the
decision should be taken other than in
accordance with the development plan
recommendation 2 is that members
delegate authority to the chief planning
officer to defend the appeal for the
reason set out under one above being
amended and or varied as may be required
three that members endorse the
recommendation that officers write to
the planning inspector requesting that
the appeal be dealt with by way of
public inquiry procedure on account of
substantial local interest and the need
for planning policy evidence to be
tested through formal questioning by an
advocates
that's it I think that's very clear and
very appropriate thank you Stephen so um
are we now ready to go to the vote
um Robert
yes chair so if members could please go
to the modern.gov app
which is and use the plus sign in the
top right hand corner to go to the vote
voting tab
and the the line for voting will be
shown in a light blue color the vote is
now in progress
so Clarity we are voting either for
refusal so we don't get confused
thank you sir all votes knowing that are
unanimously for the proposal
thank you very much indeed and thank you
very much to everyone participating and
um if we can just have a 10 minute break
please thank you very much indeed
foreign
well good morning we're still in the
morning we now move on to our next
application
um which is DC
20010 land onto the south side of Union
Road one house and I'll invite the case
officer Braun to introduce the
application to the committee if you
would please thank you Brown
thank you chair good morning and good
morning counselors just sharing my
screen for you
[Music]
so uh counselors should recall this
application from a few meetings back at
the beginning of January this is land
and south of Union Road in one house
where the committee resolved to defer
the determination of the application
so that officers could go and find out a
bit more information regarding landscape
impact and affordable housing provision
I'll just run you through the slides so
that you can re-familiarize yourself
with the location and the proposal
details
application site is in the Parish of one
house but on the western edge of the
settlement of stray Market
it's just the wider context so that you
can see the settlement or main part of
the assessment of one house in the top
of this image and
um on the right hand side you've got the
main start of the main part of Stone
Market
um the red line site which incorporates
some of the works outside the immediate
parcel of land for Access works and
drainage works
this is just context in relation to the
wider
um settlement of Stone Market
and you can see where the adjacent
Hopkins site sort of fits in as a jigsaw
piece
this image shows you the location of the
site as a proposed allocation under the
first review of the stomach area action
plan together with the Hopkins site
which is adjacent and under construction
it also shows you the location of the
children's development to the north
this is an extract from the emerging
joint local plan and shows you this
application site forming part of
proposed allocation 36 together with the
Hopkins site you can also see allocation
34 to the north which is Chilton site
this is the development framework it's
just a reminder that this application is
made in outline with all matters except
access reserved so we're looking at the
principle of development but this is an
illustrative layout as to how the site
may may accommodate the development
just to give you an idea of how it would
sit Within
context with the landscape and
surrounding development
we've got a bit of detail here about the
access arrangements so we have access
point main point into the site from
Union Road together with some Footwear
improvements through to the public
rights of way Network and the existing
pedestrian Footwear Network along Union
Road
and then a pedestrian access point onto
fimbra road on the south side of the
site again with footpath Improvement
links part of the site as well
this is an additional plan that's been
submitted following your deferral
resolution this now just clarifies the
boundary vegetation at the site which is
to either be removed or retained
as part of The Proposal so the existing
tree and hedrow planting to be retained
is shown in green
with the red hatching showing those
sections to be removed
which you can see is predominantly those
areas that make way for the access point
on along Union Road
uh you can also see there is a little
bit of copsing
um and some tree removal proposed for
the access points and
um sight Works along Finbar Road
boundary these are the photographs just
to remind you of the the context visual
context so this is Union Road looking
Southward across the site and down
towards the
um rap Valley the rat Valley is where
the special landscape area starts but
just to confirm that the site itself is
not within the special landscape area
and there are no Works proposed above
ground within the SLA the um the
drainage works is a pipe that leads from
the proposed
Suds in uh for discharge into the river
um so this Photograph looks East towards
the Hopkins site which you can see in
the background
and then the next photographs move
around towards the South and West so I
just take you through standing in the
same place and just moving around and
then this is Union Road looking East
towards the town
this is an image from the edge of the
site with the Hopkins development
looking south west across
and that's turning round again looking
slightly more West
and further west again so you've got
star House Lane behind the Hedge in the
very middle background of this image
this is Union Road at the entrance of
the Hopkins site looking towards the
application site and star House Lane
Junction
this is the junction of Union Road and
star House Lane looking down star House
Lane
this is the junction of star House Lane
and finber Road looking from the
shepherd and dog end of finber road
towards the site in the middle there and
where the pedestrians are that's fimba
Road leading towards Stone Market
and this is further along Finbar road
you can see the site behind there hedge
and the mature vegetation on the left
hand side of this picture and in the
center background you can see part of
the Hopkins site under development
and then this is looking back along
finbara road to the West towards the um
star House Lane Junction just really to
show you the difference in level between
fimber Road and the development site
this is another image of fimba Road
and this is an additional plan that has
been submitted just to help give an
understanding of the work that's been
done following the deferral resolution
on the landscape visual impact issues so
this is a landscape context plan which
gives a bit more general information
about the uh illustrative areas for
development of the site which I will try
and show you with my care so if I can
get my cursor here we go
so the likely main areas of built
development are this
pale beigey color here
and then we have landscape interface and
buffers
this
green area
the northern Gateway so that's the main
entrance to the site so with the
particular design brief dealing with how
the gateway to the development would be
planned
the open space area is planned within
this blue section along
the female road side of the site
and then we have green infrastructure
connections
through the site
here and then you have
um the green infrastructure connections
beyond the site shown with the orange
arrows and how the interconnections
between the development and adjoining
developments and The Wider Countryside
so just
to show hopefully a little bit clearer
how this would assimilate with
surrounding Countryside and other
developments in the locality you can
also see on this obviously the Hopkins
development which is on the right hand
side of this image
to the north of this plan you can see
the general layout of the Chilton leaves
development and you can see the pauper's
graves
area
shown with the asterisk and the oval
in that section there
and just another point of information
which
was something that I gave you
information on at the last meeting and
has since been queried
about bus routing I'll use this plan to
illustrate so I had a query from a local
resident about the accuracy of the
information I gave you about bus routes
in the area
I can confirm that the information I
gave you was correct but I actually have
some additional information which I can
share so the operator of a route that um
travels down finber Road this way
they do they have confirmed that they do
operate along Finbar Road
um with a request stop in the area of of
the pub but they're not currently
operating that because they're not able
to do it in a covered secure manner so
that doesn't currently run
but I also have information from the
County Council that there is an operator
confirmed for the Chilton Lee's Loop so
the operator that currently runs along
Union Road and Chilton way in this area
here the intention is for that service
to Loop through the Chilton leads
development with a bus gate
just the top of this image that you can
see there
and the expectation is that that would
loop back down Union Road past the site
so that's just to confirm that piece of
information
um so going back to the two items
that um the committee asked officers to
explore with the applicant and and third
parties last time there were two issues
the whether or not there was any
opportunity for more affordable housing
to be secured for the proposal
and
um a bit more of an assessment of the
landscape impact of the development
so starting with affordable housing
you'll know from last time that I
explained and it's in your papers that
we have had viability assessment for the
proposal and that has been through your
Consultants who also did the viability
assessment work for the joint local plan
that has concluded that the scheme can
afford 21 affordable housing on site
together with all of the other
contributions and requirements for
delivering the scheme
we went back to the infrastructure
providers and we had a discussion with
them about any flexibility in the
contributions that they're asking for
we have had agreement from the County
Council that they are willing to accept
a lesser contribution towards libraries
um they're willing to take that down
just to a books and resources
contribution
which means that that there is an amount
of just over thirty one thousand pounds
then available within viability of the
scheme which we can alternatively secure
for off-site affordable housing
provision and that 31 000 is not enough
to to be able to increase the on-site
provision
there was unfortunately no latitude in
any of the other contributions
specifically
but having spoken generally to the NHS
about the way in which they're intending
to move forward with their service
planning
and
um facilities investment going forward
and knowing what we know about the
um contributions that have been secured
for other developments in this area
including Hopkins and children's
development
and the stay market area action plan
policy which requires the cumulative and
comprehensive planning and delivery of
infrastructure what we have been able to
agree is that if the NHS contribution
amount is not allocated prior to the
first occupation of the dwellings
um on on this development if members are
minded to to Grant planning permission
then we can build in a clawback
mechanism for the 106 where that full
amount eighty four thousand pounds
defaults to be
um to be used as an affordable housing
commuted some so we're not having to pay
that back we are not losing that money
it is just you if it's not necessary
to be used for NHS services
we can have the alternative of being
able to use it as a community some for
affordable housing so
in total that takes us very close to the
amount that we would expect to have to
spend on
um on a single one or two bed home as an
affordable housing scheme
so that's
um that's some progress that we've made
in terms of the delivery of affordable
housing in general
whilst not increasing the provision on
site it does give us an opportunity to
contribute to off-site provision there
has also been some discussion about
whether an amendment of The tenure mix
for the scheme so that's the number of
properties that are made available as
shared ownership and affordable rent
would
um affect the the financial makeup of
the scheme such that we might be able to
afford more affordable housing that is
um it was an issue that was ongoing for
some time that's actually not a position
supported by your strategic housing
manager so we're not taking that forward
as a recommendation although we do have
a part of a recommendation to agree the
mix
um the recommendation is that we stay
with with our preference for 75.25 with
the preference therefore affordable
rented so that we can make sure we're
offering as a priority the majority of
those affordable dwellings to people on
the housing register
so that's where we've got to with
affordable housing which hopefully you
will agree is um is a positive
Improvement to what we had before
moving on to the landscape assessment
and you can see this plan that's on the
presentation in front of you which has
come forward as as part of a bit of
additional submission relating to the
landscape assessment
and
um some additional
work has been done with our landscape
consultant
they are generally satisfied that the
excuse me the impacts of the development
would be limited to excuse me
[Music]
sorry I pressed me took off then I
pressed unmute and it's changed my
presentation let me do that again so um
yes landscape impact so your landscape
consultant has
I accepted the additional information
that's been submitted
um by the applicant
um and their landscape advisor
um the work
Builds on that information that was done
as part of the um joint local plan for
the landscape sensitivity classification
and both parties are accepting the
sensitivity of the site and the context
the landscape context as being moderate
and that the scope of impact so we can
be we can be confident that those will
be limited generally to the site and the
immediate landscape context there are
some recommendations
from your landscape advisor that we
secure we ensure that the development
that comes forward is is in general in
accordance with what's being proposed in
terms of the vegetation removed retained
planned which I'll just take you back to
um which is something that we were
speaking about at the meeting previously
but also that we secure a scheme of
advanced boundary planting as part of
the reserve matters
um and that that that would be
sufficient to mitigate the impacts of
development in such a way that it would
be policy compliant and members can
make a decision to Grant planning
permission if you so wish
those are the two main points that came
out of
the deferral
um resolution I should just also
um confirm because there was some
discussion last time about the
sustainability scheme that that the
applicant has now included the provision
of water butts in that scheme just as an
additional measure so whilst we're still
going with the recommendation that we
need to have a scheme approved we are
specifying a couple of items which
include electric vehicle charging points
for some of the properties but now also
includes water buttons
so um that's where we've got to in terms
of the work done after the deferral
and the recommendation remains to Grant
planning permission subject to
conditions and planning obligation thank
you chair
thank you for that Bron
um can you just before I go to members
asking um questions for clarity can you
go to some of the slides you have of
your photographs
um to just demonstrate where some of the
hedging might come out I mean
unfortunately the slides weren't I
couldn't see a number on them but there
was one where you said
um east of Hopkins site there were
hedgerows in the back and then further
West starhouse Lane they were Hedges can
you just sort of show us where some of
the hedging might come out and obviously
you've just said there will be sensitive
Replacements at certain points I wonder
if you can just offer us something there
yeah of course so the main the main
difference that will be felt will be
this Northern Gateway section which is
on Union Road so that's the image that
you're seeing here
um I'll try and show you a border I've
got um a picture along Union Road so let
me show you that in a moment actually
that's that photo this Hedgerow here
that you can see on the right hand side
so a large portion of that will come out
to make way for the access point to the
site but also
um the the design element of that part
of the site so it's not to say that that
would be hard landscaped but it's to say
that that that planting would need to
come out to make way for more structured
Landscaping of the development in that
part of the site
um
apart from that
um and some smaller elements of copacing
and things like that there is also the
access point on finbra road which is
actually it's a pedestrian cycle access
point rather than a vehicular access
point so it requires far less removal of
hedging let me just take uh
at probably the best so in the
background of that image let me just go
back to the one with the pedestrians in
because that actually might be a better
one to show you
um
yeah actually probably in the in the
area roughly where those pedestrians are
maybe a little bit further back
um there will need to be some removal
there so that we can get the engineering
Works in to create the accessible
um access
rather than a stepped access so that we
so that that's possible for
um
pedestrians and cyclists
just demonstrated a little of where you
were talking about it's all very well
looking on a map yeah when you've got
some nice photographs like that it's
helpful to know what's possibly going
yeah okay so thank you for that sorry um
members to indulge my first shout at it
so does anyone wish to have some further
questions for Braun please
um and I think you might have to sort of
call out
any questions for the officer uh
councilor well hang on councilor
Mathison let's just get the committee
members oh absolutely
yeah who are the other two members I
don't know who they are
Robert can you help me
councilor Mellon do you have a question
for the officer I do cheer thank you
thank you thank you not quite sure
what's going on with the hands but
anyway um it's hopeless so my question
is um on the status of the
um Stone market area action plan
um and obviously in the papers on page
150 there's a reference to it saying
that it's out of date
um doesn't occur with the mppf
um so I'm just trying to sort of
understand
um you know we've just been discussing a
neighborhood plan which was up to date
this one isn't but it clearly has sort
of delivered the number of houses that
it was supposed to have done so far and
it's not yet this review stage can I
just sort of have a bit of clarification
about that issue
yes thank you
um yes so I think I I explained this a
little bit last time and I appreciate
it's it's we're in this area of
complexity where we're moving between
um the development plan
um as it currently is and as it's likely
to be under the under the joint local
plan but um to summarize we have
um the 98 local plan which includes some
policies which are relevant to the
determination of this application
um including H7
um because this site is outside the
settlement boundary of stowmarket as it
currently exists within the development
plan so that deals with um housing in
the countryside
um and then the area action plan which
um together with the Hopkins site which
is currently under construction
identifies this site as effectively as
an allocation it calls it a reserve site
with the potential for future housing
with the expectation that because
um that was not fully assessed at the
time of writing the area action plan
that there was intended then to be a
first review of the area erection plan
and the site together with the Insight
would would probably come forward at
that time there the
um text in the sap refers to an
approximate number of homes
to be considered
um at 200 homes so with the Hopkins site
this proposal does go beyond that figure
and that forms part of the concern
that's come from the local community
that that it's gone beyond the
um the sort of Benchmark the limit that
we had set
however
um in thinking about weight and
um delivery of the site and the
continual delivery of housing land and
looking at the emergence of the joint
local plan in which this site is a
proposed allocation taken together with
the Hopkins sign
um you can see as you said on page 115
my summary of
how much weight is to be accorded to the
policies
um in each of those elements when we're
considering
this so we're
we're sort of saying that
um
slightly less weight is given to the
policies as they are older
um because we're looking at moving
towards the joint local plan but but
that has limited weight at this stage
because it's an emerging document and
not adopted although when it is adopted
it will obviously replace the area
action plan so we're acknowledging the
um the direction of travel of the policy
but what we're really needing to do is
then
um give
more consideration to the
principles of the mppf and how the
remaining policies sit in the context of
the mppf objectives
um so we're looking for
the principles of sustainable
development so we're looking then at
where this is physically and what it
provides in terms of the contributions
that it makes to the settlements as a
whole in terms of facilities and
services Etc so that's on summarize a
little bit on your page 151
where I'm saying that there is a degree
of tension in technical terms with the
policies if you take them as read but
given the limited way or and the and the
lessening weight as we move forward on
the on the current development plan
policies we're looking more towards how
the proposal sits within the context of
the mppf objectives of delivering
sustainable development
and we've got a sustainable location
within easy walking distance of the high
school and Leisure Center
um and the bus bus for existing bus
facilities as well as the expectation
for increased bus services
um we've got a reasonable distance also
to the town and the other facilities
that are there we have the cycle
connectivity and pedestrian connectivity
that this scheme
um brings with it as well as all of the
other contributions that the more
General contributions that we would
expect to see to mitigate the
development
um I think I think really we just want
Clarity rather than them
this is only for clarity we can we can
sort of debate that ourselves I'm sure
um as one of the councilors is asked to
read all about that but that was very
fulsome and I hope that answers your
question councilor Mellon
you're muted yes yes to some extent and
it does seem to me well don't debate it
you've given the answer to the opposite
office is new and then we'll go into
debate and you can sort of bring it then
if you would
um anyone else for clarity for questions
from the officer
um there was another one as well as the
ward member who'd also asked us to read
uh various things so was there anyone
else
um Robert that you saw who wanted to ask
a question apart from the Ward member
[Music]
yes I think that's very sensible
yeah
yeah I'll just sit here and speak anyway
so there we are so um I think it's over
to you now councilor Mathison just for a
question yeah questions yes
um
yeah first one
um can we just confirm in terms of
access that the
um where the the site comes out onto
Union Road
um there will be a foot way from there
um linking to the Hopkins site footway
uh and and onward from there
um confirm that one if we can
second one is that the um
the the copying in order to achieve The
Pedestrian access onto finbra Road
um can we make sure that we
contain no no it's not can we make sure
it's a question well all right well the
question is the question is exactly how
much and no more please
um it will be removed
um because of what happened on the
adjacent Hopkins site where they took
the lot and didn't provide an access
anyway
was the um the bus service
um having established that yes in
principle
uh there is a request stop at the pub
um can we class clarify the frequency of
that service because my understanding is
twice a week
question
um
Ron can you answer that for us please
thank you chair I think Chancellor
um in terms of the access
um on Union Road and the footway I can
confirm that there is code proposed
connection footway leading along to the
Hopkins site to the West that footway
also goes all the way along to Star
House Lane around the corner of that
Junction with a dropped curb crossing
point so that we can link to the Public
Public right-of-way number 24 on the
opposite side
um in terms of
the specific details of landscaping in
respect of the access point on Finbar
Road Landscaping is a reserved matter so
we will be dealing with the specifics of
this tree that tree
um how wide that access point is and
what engineering works are required in
order to accommodate the access and any
new planting that might might be
possible to go in once the work's been
done at the reserve matters stage
um and in terms of bus service let me
just get the details that I got from the
operator bear with me just a second
thank you
[Music]
two days each week in normal
circumstances yeah that's correct
thank you for that and thank you
um counselor
Madison thank you so we now have another
question by the looks of things from
councilor Stringer off you go thank you
chair uh yeah obviously we've had quite
a lot of detail about the boundary
treatments as they are at the moment and
what is maybe likely or unlikely to be
removed do we have a relatively familiar
with this road do we not have any
photographs of the exist how it relates
to the development now being put in
because obviously the development being
put in will give you a flavor of what's
coming as it were that this will be
joining because the pictures we had
around the site boundary were basically
just of trees and hedges and mud so yeah
do we have any images of how
the frontage in Union Road relates to
the development as it's now coming down
there now
give me a second thank you yes please
[Music]
so that is the Hopkins site as it was
when I took these photographs
um middle of last year probably I think
it was it unfortunately doesn't give you
much
um of an idea of how that site boundary
will be treated because as you can see
it's still got the Harris fencing up and
it's still a load of
um muddy
um made ground but that is
um the Hopkins site leading in in the
middle background to the development
site just where that um
that giveaway sign is and then I think I
have that view the other way somewhere
no problem I think there's a glimpse of
houses on one that whoa go back
this is finbra road so this is the
southern boundary of the site which I
I'm not
um Council string equip me if I'm wrong
but I think you wanted the Union Road
treatment yeah yeah I did and a year ago
frankly there's there's a load more
houses there now you get you get a real
feel now for what is coming and how it
joins uh to inform that thing about the
sensitivity of of the of the Landscaping
here yeah I think Andrew will you
date
um okay I'm sorry I don't think I have
anything more useful than than I have
here sorry
and there might be a Google map or
something that somebody can pull up for
us during the debate counselor string or
if you can hold that thought if you
would yeah
or held here
um right so is there any other questions
for clarity for the officer please
um show your face now except mine
okay so in that case then may I ask the
parish council representative Nikki
wilshere you have three minutes to
address the committee if you would
please thank you very much
thank you
um let's get the technology working on
behalf of Parish Council I've been asked
to speak today the visual impact of this
site on the River Valley I can see that
there's been a number of drawings that
show what may be done but each of the
drawings has come with a caveat that
said it might be changed during the
design stage so it doesn't really hold a
lot of meaning and and hope for us at
this stage
um there's been a long report setting
out how good the development will be
with regards to the Landscaping but no
mention of the visual effects of this
site on the views of the river valley
and its existing landscape from the
south of the valley to walk viewing to
the north
that can be
um that will be seen what we'll be
seeing will be aspects of houses and
their roofs not the open area of arable
land that there is there at the moment
it also arose it erodes the visually
important space between one house
Village and the urban development of
Stone Market which has been an important
part of all the development plans to
date
regarding the affordable homes
we've heard about options
etc for additional funding outside but
there's no change to the existing
commitment of up to 21 which was
rejected by the committee in January
the current area action plan and the new
AP are identical regarding this site Lao
36 the area of Reserve green site under
the previous action plan
but as the existing document is old and
about disregarded and the new plan still
has not been adopted
under the current the actual current sap
one house is a classified as a secondary
Village and not suitable for major
development
and under the new unadopted joint plan
we are reclassified as one of 46
hinterlands
the new planning document sp04 suggests
that over a period of 19 years in
mid-suffolk that approximately 1200 or
10 of new homes so we accommodated which
is 67 houses a year between 46 villages
the additional application of up to 146
dwellings would be fair to be far in
excess that could be considered
reasonable for us or any other
Hinterland Village
with over development of over 45 percent
in the encroachment into one house and
the further destruction of our Parish
and for these reasons the parish council
asks you not just to defer this
application but to reject it
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed do members
have questions for Nikki Wilshire please
if you'd like to put yourself forward on
screen and we can see who has a question
not at this stage thank you Nikki
Wiltshire
um I just wonder if the officer can just
clarify for me um the statement was made
there was that um the committee rejected
uh the issue I I think it was deferred
is that correct
yeah the meeting on the 6th of January
the resolution was to defer to defer
right yeah okay but the comments were
probably
um included in that right so anyone else
wishing to have questions no
in that case then um Robert if I can
concur actually um Ron if you just take
your presentation off for a minute
yeah just a matter of just for clarity
the committee there is a motion for
approval which fell
at the last time we looked at this and
then there was a motion to differ
oh I see yes it right yeah so yeah
correct okay
but it fell so it was it wasn't um
accepted yeah okay
um now then where was I oh yes um Robert
if you can concur is that now glennis
Bailon that we have as an objector is
that correct for the next speaker
thank you
um glennis balam if you would like to
switch your camera on and you have three
minutes thank you
can you hear me yes very clear thank you
I wish to object to this application for
the following reasons it appears more
concern is giving to developers profits
why should I be allowed to ignore
mid-suffic District Council policy of 35
social affordable housing with their
proposal of only 21 because they say the
site is difficult and costly to develop
was it the developer who requested to
build 146 houses on this site that has
only has a vacancy left for 100 on the
existing and new and mid-sufficient
District Council policy saap for
la036 this is an overbuild of almost 50
percent is this another policy that can
be broken to help the developer
has anyone from this committee visited
the site an area to see the existing
problems we have in the area and to
study the potential extra problems that
will be caused if this development is
granted
my major concern is flooding on finbler
road we have suffered with three floods
in the past four years are these the
so-called once in a hundred years floods
finber road is permanently wet now
caused by water seeping through from the
Hopkins home site
it is mentioned on the portal that the
site will not flood I should hope not as
this site is Sun three meters above
finber road so if it did many houses
would be underwater
the proposed pathway leading from the
site to Lower Road has recently been
impossible for several months due to
constantly flooding on the road some of
this caused through a constant flow of
water running down star House Lane from
Union Road we have not experienced water
running down star House Lane previously
but have had the flooding on the road
making the path impassable
the roads and lions in this area were
built for horse and carts not the
constant traffic of cars fans and
lorries as it is now and will be much
worse with another 146 houses and also
from the plus 300 that are under
construction in this small area
as soon as star house line is repaired
potholes reappear
regarding the in visual impact of this
development on the river rat Austin
Valley I know a number of very pretty
drawings have been added which clearly
state are not for planning and would be
changed during design period could be
changed the report and refers to the
layout designed with new reference to
the visual impact on the valley and
can't decide when viewed from the South
Bank to the north
it's a committee members through this
site from the top of the same spank from
wasps Farm you will be able to see the
Dreadful impact of the current 300 House
Development thank you
thank you very much
um now do members have any questions for
glennis balam at all please if you would
can you just put your videos on
thank you for your very clear statement
um I think no there are no further
questions if you'd like to turn your
video and sound off thank you very much
this is Dylan if you turn the video off
thank you
um can I just have um
a comment from the planning officer
please
um glennis Baylin said that flooding is
occurring from seeping from Hopkins side
um that's quite a statement
um and I wonder
if that can be addressed outside this
committee please
um if an officer can pick that up please
yeah thank you chair I understand we
have one of our important officers with
a live investigation regarding the
Hopkins sites just a reminder that that
doesn't form any part of this
application but it is being investigated
as I understand it yes thank you and I
wanted that clear that it is not to do
with this side thank you very much
indeed right
um so
we
we but I'm sure
yes Humphries is this a question yes
there's a point of clarifications I
guess
um just confirm that that investigation
is talking about the seeping of the
water from Hopkins site or whether it's
an investigation into the ditches that
full of water on the Northern side
because I think that's where the
investigation is at the moment because
I'm part of it as in I raised it so can
you just confirm that please
thank you councilor um I'm not really
sure I can share the specific details of
an ongoing investigation
um but suffice to say that there are
complaints relating to various aspects
of the Hopkins development site
including flood risk and other matters
and that our enforcement team are
looking into them thank you yeah thank
you yeah thank you for that
um moving on now we have the applicant
uh Robert Barber if you would like to
have three minutes and tell us about the
site please thank you
uh thank you madam chair and members
um I do also have with me today our
landscape consultant James Atkin who
would be happy to answer any questions
on that on that particular matter and
and I would also just like very quickly
to clear up a matter in relation to the
first question you still only have three
minutes I have no idea I do and it and
it was something I dealt with at um in
our last presentation relation in
relation to the status of the policies
and we concluded that and as was
outlined in the officer report that the
mppf's presumption in favor of
sustainable development I.E paragraph 11
D2 is active in this case thank you
however since the Throne of of the
application we've worked closely with
officers and the statutory consultees to
to respond positively to the two reasons
for a deferral the officer has outlined
uh where we've got to in terms of those
discussions uh but I think it is a
positive way forward and the uh the uh
applicant is is
um uh content that we have uh reached a
a positive position and importantly
um it hasn't resulted it's resulted in a
an additional uh contribution towards at
affordable housing but has not uh
resulted in uh the change to the uh
tenure split which remains at 75
affordable rent and 25 shared ownership
and therefore does not rely on the
discounted Market tenure as both Hopkins
and the Taylor wimpy children Leeds
developments do
uh the the exhaustive uh viability
appraisal that's already been undertaken
uh by ask Bill Verdi who has already
been mentioned uh were responsible for
the viability testing of the local plan
um has has been thorough and
um and we've got to the position we've
got to today
uh we initially evidenced the 15
affordable housing provision but we've
now accepted that a 21 is is achievable
but that has an A A knock-on impact on
the level of developer profit
uh the planning application as before
you today remains policy compliant in
respect of its approach to affordable
housing and all avenues to increase the
overall percentage have been explored
and that has been done in uh cooperation
with your offices and statutory
consultees in respect of landscape
impact the applicant has submitted
further information to demonstrate how a
reserve matters scheme can successfully
integrate and respect the character of
the area and that includes a vegetation
plan and the land landscape context plan
the framework plan provides an
indicative provision of public open
space that is 10 times the policy
requirement
set out to guide the reserve matters a
landscape and visual note which contains
some design guidance and strategies for
the reserve matters stage now forms part
of a proposed new planning condition
this condition also allows a plan that
provides members three minutes
I would just in light of the information
and discussions that we've had
respectively request that the
application is approved in line with
officer recommendations thank you thank
you for that now then members do you
have any uh question uh regarding uh the
statement that Mr Barber has just made
um
anybody
wishing to speak no Mr act I can see
councilor Matheson's hand yeah right
um if there's no other member of the
committee councilor Mathison if you'd
like to ask your question thank you
thank you yes will you
um
will you be when when you go to reserved
matters and the design and the layout in
detail will you be taking full
um use of the orientation of the site
which is strongly favorably self-facing
uh sloping well South sloping thank you
um yeah the the layout and design
um at Reserve matter stage
um is something that will be um
undertaken by a prospective purchaser
um that they are required uh to follow
uh uh good design practice and that
includes making use of orientation uh uh
uh as as well as other matters
um I think I think to be fair that's
going to be dealt with that Reserve
matters and I'll let the question go
um because it you know obviously an
important question but I think that
needs to be dealt with Reserve matters
yeah I I I agree and I was going to say
that your officers have the ability to
um uh review any uh layouts thank you
yeah let's leave it at that councilor
Mathison do you have another question
relevant to the application today I
don't know that Mr Barbers clarified
that he's not the ultimate developer and
that's well yeah okay thank you thank
you thank you thank you uh right so in
fact we now come on to your good self
councilor Mathison so if you'd like to
tell us about your
right comments thank you
right yeah I'd first like to to talk
about the landscape for a moment
um the officer had a very good
um
a couple of photographs right in the
middle of the presentation of looking
south from Union Road which showed the
The Wider landscape view that will be
lost I think I'd be grateful if if that
could find its way up onto the screen
um
and the the the point the point being as
it is it's we find it
um is that that that view is is quite
valued locally across we can see about
something like a two miles across to
little finbra and combs Village
and um
the the Hopkins development has has
actually closed off
what part of that view already
um not that one
um
yeah I think you can just begin to see
there in the very the very dis yeah
it's gone again yeah that one you can
you can very you can see just a little
clump of trees
um that that is kind of halfway across
to to little finbra uh and there are
other various um views similar to that
one which which will be lost
by by building out this development and
so that then all of that is the
landscape impact that hasn't actually
really been discussed or considered
um but it would be lost and also on the
Landscaping you've heard from the parish
council that the um that the saap did
ask that the gap between town and
Village was maintained and certainly
this this erodes it quite a bit further
this this proposal
um turning to the numbers of houses
um we've heard that the
um the saap and and seemingly the
emerging joint local plan both
um think in terms of these this
allocation which is to say these two
sites this site and the Hopkins site
um with a with a ballpark figure of 400
um and and this
this would take it in fact to to 446.
um because 300 have already been
approved and it just for members to note
you saw the Chilton lays
um on one of the early plans that was
put up on screen
um up there that there are under
construction or well the first couple of
hundred are already occupied
um some 1100 homes being built in that
area thank you
um yes so one part of the LA
um 034
is now built together with the
allocation of a
um Primary School site
um 1100 all together in in the area
already being built or approved let's
say
um
you've heard a little bit about the
flooding the problem really is that the
theory of the flooding
um isn't being borne out in practice and
whether that's because the rain is is
heavier and more frequent or whether the
the soil conditions
um on these two sites has
is not the standard average whatever
that the theory assumes
um the reality is that flooding is a big
problem pictures have been provided of
just how astonishing the flooding can be
in terms of closing roads closing foot
passes Mrs balam has said and
um that is not happening once in a
whatever it's it's happening I think
someone was suggested that the the roads
have been closed four four times in in
ten years
um several of which were actually
recently recent years so
there is there is a problem and and
whether the the
recommended measures for this site will
be sufficient to not make matters worse
uh is is on it's much an open question
unfortunately at the moment I'd like to
turn to The Stone Market area action
plan and this is the current adopted
local plan relevant to this site
um now we've heard well it's not really
fully in accordance with the mppf but
but H7 which was mentioned isn't part of
the S if the saap anyway it's it's it's
separate to it
um and um I think that
at the moment
join local plan has not been adopted it
has limited weight and we should respect
the people who and hundreds and hundreds
of people who contributed their views to
the construction of the stowmarket area
action plan which as I've said is the
adopted policy so finally the question
of balance and I think what I have to
ask members is whether the
um where there are there are sufficient
advantages here
notably the fact that it the site is not
able to deliver the full policy of 35
affordable houses
um whether there are sufficient
advantages and reasons to actually add a
yet another 146 houses onto the number
that I've already just outlined that are
being built
um when the site is not viable
to do to produce the affordables that we
would like to see so you know why why
why bend the policies why bend the
policies at the moment in order to
produce
of such a limited advantage
so I I would ask you to refuse it please
thank you for that councilor Stringer
just as a point of accuracy our policy
says up to 35 it doesn't say it has five
percent
um however um if members have questions
of the ward member for his
considerations would you like to put
your video on to ask a question of
councilor Madison
no
thank you John thank you for your time
there
so if you thank you
so
questions for the ward member
We Now open up to debate
I don't think we have anyone else
so can we go to councilor custom first
thank you
councilor Kasten
have we lost councilor caster
Robert can you find
uh I don't believe we've lost counts the
castle because he's still he's unmuted
now
kick off yes we've got you thank you oh
you've got me okay it says that I'm
muted on my M screen
and you can see me yeah that's fine yeah
sorry but yeah they've gone they've gone
right now it says that I'm unmuted yeah
we've got some technology today I do
apologize yeah so
um yeah I've the um proposer for
approval in the last time we looked at
this it not a lot really changed for me
I'd welcome the um Resource Management
um efforts with the water bats
um there's been a bit of work done on
that affordable
housing
um still not particularly happy with
that but I understand there's a
president being set on surrounding
developments the um
that make things um quite difficult
um the um
um I think this is a sustainable
location
um the there's good connectivity those
the the bus routers are not ideal but um
the you know the more demand for the
services the more likely it is that
there'll be a viable service
um come in and um I can't see many
places in mid-suffolk that um wouldn't
be more viable than this area you know
in on the edge of Stone Market so um
yeah not much changed for me the um the
flood
issue I don't believe to be an issue
um I don't I I don't believe I think
that this um this site is has dealt with
runoff
um I I don't I don't believe that to be
a problem so um yeah thank you very much
thank you very much
okay thank you councilor Kirsten uh we
then have counselor Gould please thank
you very much Madam chair
um I'm not a great deal to add to
um uh what cancer customers just said I
I think uh he sums up the position uh
very well I did to have a slight
question
about the how material the
um the joint local plan is given its
current status
I'm mindful of having read something I
think in the last week or so about the
art High courts
um uh refusal of the judicial review
application for woolpit which I think
did seem to give it some materiality and
I'd I'd just be grateful to take the
opportunity to get some clarification on
that but in terms of this application uh
as it is I'm highly in the court with
what uh councilor casting has said
yes thank you for that
um I must admit I did pick up um when I
was
um listening to people is that the joint
local plan is used for things or against
it as its basis where it is at the
moment when it's
useful in one way or the other a very
difficult situation I wonder if um John
pateman G can give us a bit of help on
that please
hello there um right I'm not gone live
on my camera I do apologize I just I've
got two children both on live Zoom
meetings with their teachers at the
moment so I think I'll break the
internet if I go live
um but in respect of the uh common
position where we are so
that we don't have a name of a plan in
this case
um we do have uh various uh development
plan documents which is the local plan
we have a area action plan and the core
strategy and we have gone through those
documents to determine
um you know if they are considered to be
in date and we have gone through that
process and we have concluded as
officers that in this case that the
Tilted balance does engage because the
policies are the most important policies
that are relevant and we should say the
most important policies that are
relevant to the site because things are
very much on a site-specific basis but
the relevant policies are applicable to
the site uh and and the nature of the
development housing in this case uh are
considered to be out of date now that
has been upheld in various appeals will
pit probably is the most famous one but
there are others
um where we have gone through the
analysis of how those policies do not
readily conform with the nppf and it is
on that basis that we have this position
and the policy position that we have to
take which the nppf
seeks those material consideration to
take into account is that the
um you know we should Grant planning
permission unless any adverse impacts of
doing so would significantly and
demonstratively outweigh the benefits
and we so if we do go down any other
road we have to look at the adverse
impacts but we have to see if they ask
significantly and we have to argue that
they demonstration are demonstratable to
outweigh the benefits When assessed
against the uh nppf
um does that help yes I think it does a
knee and do you want to just confirm
please I better jump in yes I wanted
John to go first but yeah the wool pit
the high court decision it was handed
down about 10 days maybe more um I was
in the virtual courtroom and I listened
to it and I've just been going back in
my notebook I did write no notes of
essential parts of the judgment and I'm
not going to try and read my own
handwriting on on the hoof but I yeah I
mean essentially for John is exactly
right I agree with every word of water
the advice he's just given you
um the wool pit the Judgment the high
court judgment of Mr Justice holgates
it's we haven't we all heard it those of
us who are in the virtual courtroom but
it's not yet
official in the sense that we're still
waiting for a shorthand writer to type
it up and for Mr Justice Holgate to
check it and release it officially
unless it's happened in the last day or
so and it hasn't reached me but I don't
think it has but yeah there is there's
certainly nothing in that judgment I can
confirm that's that says anything other
than what you've been advised today in
this report or by your officers so far
thank you for that in that's very
comforting and councilor Gould does that
help you with your understanding thank
you I appreciate that uh thank you very
much yeah yeah thank you for that right
moving on councilor Humphries if you
would please thank you
fine I'll try not to keep too long I'll
go back a little bit to um to Nikki
Walsh's uh points um she's absolutely
right once this error is lost the visual
views they've gone forever but that's
true of any development and fairness but
it is quite sad and it's a it's a shame
in some respect that The Stone Market
area action plan in its eight years of
existence hasn't been reviewed because
if it had been a lot of what we've done
today and discussed today might be a lot
clearer
um and actually might have matched up
with the joint local planets emerging
that's identified this area that's
suitable for development and in fact
it's already started with the Hopkins
Home Development as well
um if I can go on to the sustainability
side of it it is a sustainable location
it's close to Stow Market in fact it's
right up against it which is absolutely
one of the points isn't it that actually
there's a butts with one house but of
course one house Village the core
Village is not actually affected by this
development it's quite some distance
away and it's arguably the same as the
children leads the state in respect to
the core and Village of one house
however it does uh butt up against the
boundary and I understand that however
the area is sustainable
sustainable for many ways one you can
walk into town two you can cycle into
town and three when we come onto the bus
routes we talked about the buses but as
we talked about the bus down at the pub
which is twice a week you can now walk
to the pub or will be able to because
there'll be a footpath through the
estate and that's got to be a good thing
it also allows you to go to the cafe at
Riverside or the Lakeside Cafe sorry so
that's also a good thing
um there are buses and there are good
bus routes very close to this
development in fact within 300 meters
and I might be overestimating that there
is a bus stop for uh Route 88 which
takes you into stone Market regularly
generally every half hour auto IPS which
so there is good access it's also
extremely close to shops local shops on
and there'll be one on Chilton leaves
and schools one and short Legion of
course high school that is just across
the road from this actual development so
sustainability it takes pretty much
every box
um and I think it's got to be supported
for that in that respect
um I do understand Mrs Bonham's point
about the flooding I do live in a local
area and I do understand all the
concerns of the residents in one house
and also locally in stowmarket about the
position of this development
I also understand the perception and
perhaps actually lived lived experience
would say that there is an increase in
Flooding at the bottom of the hill
towards the pub and the Junctions
um
I've witnessed that but I don't know as
councilor Mathison said what the science
is behind that and facts is it because
we found an unusual amount of rainfall
recently is it because the soil content
containing more water I don't know but
he's right and she's right there has
been increase of water but I don't know
if it's connected and I don't know if
it'll get worse because if you read the
reports it says actually they're going
to make it better okay so therefore
there should be less water and that's to
be decided and and to be evidenced in
the future
um coming back to it the joint local
plan identifies this areas develop the
development Hopkins is part of that same
area that's already started the
development
um so the Preston's already been set
um
I just can't honestly find a planning
reason to refuse this application but a
wood actually ask
that when they do develop this uh this
area that they pay considerable
consideration to the flooding risk which
is encouraged I think and also to the
Hedge roads and the tree lines that we
now have the same effect that happened
on Hopkins estate
um I've noticed there's quite a lot of
hedgerows and trees being ripped out on
the plan that I saw earlier on
um I think that needs to be looked at it
needs to be considered and we need to
maintain as much Hedgerow as much tree
line or replace it with light for like
almost as possible because it's it's
wrong to rip it out if there's no
requirement and I'll go back finally to
Mrs balance point just give it a little
bit of balance I agree there in some
degree that um the developer's telling
us there's not enough profit in it to
allow
um for
um for more social housing
well if there isn't enough money in
something as a business why do it that
would be my point on that but it is a
business decision which is outside of
this planning committee I believe but
her point was valid
um so I'm minded to go for approval
um
because I can't find a major reason for
refusal
thank you
thank you councilor Humphries councilman
uh yeah thank you chair
um I don't think this
um this application is as
straightforward as the papers would
suggest I think there's an honest
complexity to it
um the site is within the Parish of one
house but uh or one as I should say but
functionally it's attached to the edge
of of the town
I don't think we can dismiss the
concerns about flooding
um that that is what residents and users
of finber Road are experiencing now I
know we've had a very very wet December
and January I think someone reported it
as the wettest in a hundred years
um but that is what we should expect
from global warming that's what we've
been told to expect
um the the question is really is the
recent flooding in that area
related to the construction phase of the
other development or is it a systemic
problem with this site
and will development contribute to the
problem well I think that's still an
open question
um I did propose deferral of this
application two meetings ago because I
wanted to see if we could get a higher
figure for affordables
and I think we've got our answer which
is clearly no
um the agent talked about an additional
contribution but I don't see that they
have made any additional contribution
they've just shuffled things around a
little bit
um and have dug their heels in
um so I note that
in terms of the landscape in impacts
you you can't dress it up
views will be lost particularly from
South across the rat Valley so I still
find myself
um in in two minds about this
application and I'll listen to the
debate further thank you
thank you councilor melon
so we now go on to councilor Norris
can I just remind you that when we do
talk about it we shouldn't really be
looking at the site next door to us as
to what's going on there it's this side
and this should consume its own smoke so
I'll just remind members of that thank
you councilor Norris please your views
thank you thank you madam chair
I will just talk about this site
um
I still have considerable reservations
regarding this application
the site is in the countryside and it's
outside settlement boundaries it erodes
the demarcation between one house and
Stone Market
I know this area very well and if you
travel up from fembroke Road up star
House Lane which will run alongside this
application site that's quite an incline
in fact you saw in I don't know whether
people picked it up but in their
photograph acts of the junction between
um Union Road and star house lion
star house land disappears down the
slope actually
the runoff act it's quite it is quite an
incline I can assure you
the runoff from development on this site
that's the one yes in fact
oh well yes all right on the next one
and it drops off from you know star
house line is disappearing off it's also
into the right hand side of the
photograph you see on the screen and the
next photograph if the office at that
one you can see Star House Lane comes
out at an incline down onto finber road
so the whole site is in
an elevated position and any development
on this side
it can only access accessorbate the
problem that we have seen photographs of
on the previous presentation and this um
application when it came to committee on
the 6th of January
and also if we look at the
late papers from the chair of one house
Parish Council the top of the second
page of her
submission
it is mentioned that there have been
road closures of four times in six weeks
during December and January well yes
okay going back
to what was just mentioned about
December and January being the West for
a hundred years but
I have seen evidence of the flooding for
myself and it is considerable and I
really do think that any develop can
really only add to the problem even more
um
I do question also whether there is any
proven evidence of local need for this
development if we go back to the email
that the ward member sent the second
bullet point that he listed mentioned
that the allocations included for this
part of Stone Market have already been
exceeded so I questioned the
justification for this application uh
in itself
that's all I will say at this time I'm
tending towards not supporting the
recommendation thank you
thank you for that councilor Norris and
now we come on to councilor Stringer if
you would please thank you thank you
chair thank you chair uh yeah just want
to focus on I think three different
elements I'll start with the smallest
one first that's that one of public
transport
uh to have the closest bus service twice
a week in what is let's face it an
extension to the town of Stone Market is
is not really heading towards
sustainable and if indeed another bus
stop is is 300 meters away if I could
walk 300 meters I probably wouldn't need
a bus
so it does it seems to sort of not quite
you know hit all the buttons you're
supposed to be pushing if you're
building sustainable development and
sustainable development that's actually
in a town but it's actually in in very
very open Countryside and that's where I
come to one of landscape impact
uh and we're not helped here uh we've
got a series of photographs in the
presentation that that doesn't show
how it relates to the development coming
down the hill
uh and of course Google Street View
doesn't help us here either because
street view is 12 years old
and if you if you were to look on street
view now
and then look at the same Vista now
you'll see what is highly likely to come
if this is approved and frankly in
landscape terms it is totally
devastating and I don't underestimate
that term
which is why I personally can't support
this application until the landscape
impact is known to me
now I'm not saying I'm going to get
precious about every single edge
what I'm saying is I can't make the
decision until I'm shown the information
and that information has not been shown
to me
so therefore I can't support it in
landscape impact terms because
using the evidence that I have which is
the evidence of my own eyes
I would have to say the impact could be
devastating
and I can't unleash that on on Midsouth
at Countryside not into a Gateway site
like this because this will be a Gateway
site
as people arrive from the south this
development will be high on a hill it
will be it will be a huge Gateway
development and we need to work out what
that impact is now getting to the
flooding I'm not interested where the
water's coming from
I'm interested in why it's sitting in
that road for weeks on end
even if you do link a footpath into the
south end of this site if you want to
walk to the cafe
or walk to the bus stop or walk to the
pub you'll need a set of waders or a
dinghy
which also doesn't really hit the first
principles of sustainable development
now I'm not suggesting where it's coming
from this is at the moment if you look
on the highways reporting tool and you
look at the boundaries of this site
there are 27 current reports of faults
in the highway in flooding and potholes
surrounding this site that's giving you
a clear indication there are existing
issues here that desperate in need of
resolving uh equally uh the mppf does
help us here where it says we need to
plan for climate change 148 through 2
154 says exactly what we should be doing
here and to my mind with the evidence I
have at the moment
this application does not allow me to
comply with those paragraphs it equally
does not deliver the full amount of
affordable housing that it could and I
believe it should because if we cannot
deliver the full amount in our biggest
settlements and we then rely on our
villagers to mop up more of that need
that is also pushing at the boundaries
of sustainability for me so I don't know
whether I'll be voting against uh this
application but I certainly feel I can't
vote for it thank you chair
uh thank you for that can I just have a
bit of clarity please um from the
planning officer
um aren't the landscape things going to
be dealt with at Reserve matters and
isn't that what we're supposed to be
looking at there yeah that's right sorry
if you want to answer that point I've
actually got a few more points Joe if I
may come in yeah yeah
yeah Landscaping is a reserved matter so
it's not matter for consideration here
although in dealing with the principle
of development it is appropriate that
the committee give regard to the general
absolutely absolutely
because we make strong views so that's
absolutely it
um yes John if you'd like to come in
what are your other issues sir yeah so
there's been a few things mentioned and
I think we need to be careful in what
information we think we have available
um and how we're making possible
decisions on on the information
available uh just going back to the
Landscaping very quickly uh ultimately
yes Landscaping is a reserve matter but
what you're dealing with here is the
principle of development on this side
and whether you think that any
development on this site of this level
proposed would have a detrimental impact
on the on the surrounding landscape and
if that is the case then you're saying
that the principle of development for
that many houses is a problem
um or is it a problem that you think
that there can be a solution by reason
of layout and design and Landscaping
that would not cause such adverse harm
against the benefits of the development
in terms of the criteria of the mppf so
that's what you need to be fought about
in terms of the Landscaping side of
things I will just mention buses
um I think Bowman has outlined the
existing situation in terms of the bus
routes of the area but I will point out
that there will be a new bus service
that does drop into this site so part of
the North Hills application which is
also known as Chilton Lee's at the top
that includes a new bus route and it
hasn't quite reached the occupation
level to trigger that 106 requirement
but when it does you will find there's a
bus gate essentially coming out I
haven't got a map in front of me but it
comes out quite close to this site and
what you end up with is a loop that will
go around uh Stow market and I would
imagine it will be daily considering the
uh the amount of uh uh residents that
will be along this route it will come
out and it will go round and and join
back into stone market so there will be
a loop bus route in this area that will
be developing very very soon and I think
as that is a material consideration we
shouldn't forget that
um in respect of this proposal it has
been secured the funding is there it is
just a matter of reaching the trigger
point for the 106 agreement for Chilton
leaves
um there has been a lot mentioned about
the allocations now on this point I
would have to take further advice uh
possibly from Bowman but possibly from
our policy team
um the stern market area action plan and
its position in terms of its fulfillment
of um the number of dwellings that it uh
allocated I don't have the details of I
do know though that there are gaps
within the uh the housing allocations
for example children leaves was an
allocation of a thousand houses but only
815 would have been secured by the end
of it
um we also have the ashes site that
hasn't come forward in this time frame
and unfortunately I've forgotten how
many houses were on that side so there
are gaps in The Stone Market area action
plan uh and I think if we start talking
about housing need as a question we
would recommend that we'd have to go
away and look at that to make sure we
have the full facts uh in respect of the
the housing in the locality
um flood has been mentioned
um obviously there is a local concern
the question here is does this
development add to any current problem
or does it essentially deal with its own
burden and in actual fact the
requirement from our flood colleagues in
the county from the flood team is that
it has an at least a 10 uh betterment in
respect of flood risk so
in theory there should be an improvement
to the general area but the minimum
requirement is that it actually does
deal with its own flood risk and we have
our we are reliant on the flood team
giving us uh their expertise on this
matter and they are not opposing this
development
in respect of your affordable housing
policy
the question here is your policy does
allow for flexibility
it does allow for viability to be
considered and I would also say that the
adjacent developments of Union mode and
children Lees didn't achieve 35 of
audible housing either they all average
out at around about 20 percent
and this in many respects would be
consistent with that and I would find it
difficult I suggest to defend a refusal
if it was based on the affordable
housing not being up to 35 well not
achieving 35 percent
so I hope that helps members a little
bit more uh in respect of this debate
thank you yeah I I do have a question
actually
um
presumably the sill payments that go to
one house wouldn't they
shouldn't be seal payments there's no
payments on this at all then but this is
a strategic site is that right bombing
that should be the case
that's right yeah this is all this is
all 106. oh 106. okay sorry nothing that
is why for example Chevrolet uh
libraries is part of the uh 106 here
whereas in normal situation still would
have taken on board libraries and it
would have been just dealt with as part
of cell so this is a tajiki site so the
method of those things are different in
in this particular location okay thank
we may now please thank you
sorry
that's all right off you go there we go
yes
um just digesting uh
Mr pigment juice comments really
um
I first started looking at this as this
going forward you know I acknowledge the
the work
um officer Braun has done uh working
with the council's landscape advisor and
the um
applicant's own Consultants
I think what I really welcome is that
there's they've recognized that this is
a sensitive visual area
uh although it's not as a special visual
area it does sit between two
special visual areas so it is sensitive
um I welcome some of the
measures which I I believe are
conditions that should be attached to
this as particularly Advanced boundary
planning and I realize that details will
be worked out at
um
at the the next application
it is a sensitive site it is a south
facing slope in sight so
we are going to be looking at a lot of
houses on the hillside
uh which brings me over to the the
question of water it is a sloping site
uh mitigation measures talk about 10
percent
letterment
um we've mentioned water butts uh I've
got some water but the full to the brim
they're not going to mitigate any
further rainfall this spring
uh and that's what I think happens with
plan mitigation measures that they get
full to the brim and then they're no
longer mitigation measures
um
we've got evidence of
flood waters on uh I'll get the roads
right finberry road that thing is it
along the bottom along the river rat
and um Down star House Lane which runs
with water
uh and I think
these are concerns that need to be
addressed perhaps as that before there's
any further development I my feeling is
this this sort of is beginning to hinge
around
I up to date
local plans are the stone architecture
plan our own emerging local plan
um
which I feel is a little bit
unsatisfactory I'd like to see
because
of the community's concerns about this
development that it's it's excessive
um
it's it's not really relevant to
community needs we we know already that
it 21 affordable housing is not really
are recommended
uh recognition of community needs
um
so I'm concerned I'm not certain that I
could really support
this development wholeheartedly I agree
there are questions about it and perhaps
but I'd like to put the weight in
more towards the local action plans
um
my question is whether it could be
really cluster sustainable development
if it doesn't answer Community needs
thank you
thank you for that Council of all boys
um so listening to everybody and
listening
um to all the things that have been
presented before us
um
I think I'm right in saying and I will
just ask John for clarification on this
that when we do look at planning
applications can you turn your video off
please councilor War boys
um
when we do look at all these
applications we actually look at
mid-suffolk as a whole
am I right in that
um
John
yeah so
um unless specifically narrowed down
yes yeah okay right thank you so I hear
what everybody's saying and I thought it
was very useful that councilor Humphries
told us
um that he lives close by and
um Witnesses the flooding issues and
involved in various issues there I used
to drive from Walker to stowmarket
regularly so I know the area quite well
but not of recent date I have to say
um but um counselor Stringer also
mentioned that we need waders and a
dinghy I can lend him one
um but not being flippant about it
um the problem appears to be there at
the moment which I find quite disturbing
um and listening to the local residents
you can see exactly why they are
concerned about this I too had an
application in debenham members may
recall and the road flooded from one end
to the other
but it was felt that there was
sufficient mitigating circumstances and
the application was put through well I'm
not complaining about that I'm just
pointing out that these things happen
um and I think it is very worrying
um
with with the flooding issue
um but if it's going to be betterment I
like the sound of that
um I I also think it is actually a
sustainable development now we don't
know fully on the on the buses and with
the current situation in lockdown I
think it's very difficult for everybody
to judge
um appropriateness of public transport
but it does seem appropriate that there
is going to be something in place which
encourages me
and it's easy for me to sit here and and
sort of say well yes you know
um we'll put it through
um you know we don't need any more
information
um but my problem is the same counselor
Humphreys is
this will be going forward as a site
allocation and
if the applicant has worked very very
hard along with the officers I think
they can hear as loud and clear as to
what our concerns are
so at the moment I would be more
inclined because we have this Reserve
matters always frustrates all of us and
and the public too is well why can't you
sort it out now well we can't
so I'm I'm more inclined to say that you
know this site will come forward a lot
of work has been done on it there's a
lot of good things there
um
and I'd be more inclined to to vote with
the recommendation at the moment but
they're My Views at the moment but I'm
still
anxious for the local community so does
anyone else want to sort of go a second
time round or make a proposal or
counselor Humphreys I might show you a
second go around I think because it is
quite important can I just confirm in
the offices please uh on one point on
the reserve matters
um because we're gonna if it goes
forward that to plan the officer
authorized to Grant outline plan person
based on blah blah blah and one of them
is said conditions is that where we will
get to discuss in detail the uh
mitigation to reduce or better uh the
water drainage issue that is evidently
there right now uh if you could answer
that that'd be great and they'll carry
on if you don't mind
yeah
you pronounced that chair thank you
um no is the quick answer to that that
it is a requirement at this stage that
the application include a flood risk
assessment and a full sustainable Urban
drainage strategy which has been through
consultation responsibility for that
lies with the county councilors lead
local flood Authority we've also
consulted with the environment agency
and the internal drainage board because
of the slight overlap of
responsibilities under under the
relevant legislation but in every case
there is no objection to the proposal
there are recommendations for conditions
which ensure that the strategy that's
being proposed is carried out as
outlined in the in the documents that
have been submitted that includes the
detention Basin that's within the
proposal
um with the regulated outflow
to the river and as John has outlined
the betterment of the existing
runoff rate
thank you that's a real soon but I
understand it and I think there perhaps
is enough detail here and we do
as much as we feel otherwise the the
evidence has been provided by those
authorities so we can't
well isn't it we just can't question it
I suppose it is what it is but the
betterment is the bit that I like I'd
like to go back to the bus stop bit and
we're getting smoking mirrors here a
little bit from from some people
um there is a good bus service if you
can walk 300 meters doesn't mean you can
walk to Ipswich so there are there are
good bus routes in place and I've just
checked actually and the officers are
correct the new bus route there's
already two new bus stops for that route
on the new estate children's which will
obviously continue so I'm satisfied with
the sustainability side of it as well
especially the bus routes
um yeah that's it I'm mining to approve
but um
even though I feel the way I feel about
the the the evidence of the flooding at
the moment maybe the betterment will
reduce it
thank you
if you've said you're minded to approve
are you are you recommending it or are
you just minded to approve I don't know
um thank you I'll just wait for other
countries to respond because I'm sorry
thank you right so we'd like to put
themselves up as a video so I know you
want to speak a second time if you would
please
who's coming forward for that counselor
Stringer yes off you go thank you yeah
no the the reason for the comment about
the buses if I could walk 300 meters
I'll probably catch a train that's what
I was meaning because you're nearly at
the train station by then uh we there's
been this discussion about betterment I
just want to we're only talking about
this site
so if we if we took a hundred percent of
the water off this site
I still believe there would be flooding
in that road because I think that's what
the evidence shows
so
um and the County Council come in on
that
apologies to a councilman
um yeah ultimately the the application
is doesn't would not resolve the
existing issue so that it that is you
know that is correct and I think even if
uh the 10 that is sort of the standard
requirement for sustainable drainage
that the county uh embarks on achieving
even if that was achieved I don't think
the 10 would be overly noticeable in
realistic terms in in respect of of the
flood risk but the point here is that
the application has to deal with its own
and not add and that is where we have to
deal with it in planning terms my
apologies for interrupting in terms okay
I was trying to say um actually
um whilst I appreciate John's
intervention I think we need counselor
Stringer to continue with his uh
statements yes I I totally agree with
what John paintman G just said that's
very helpful because it I'm not the bit
about flooding is not about what's
happening in around this site it it's
the fact that the flooding that exists
already wherever it's coming from would
mean you can't access
the sustainability measures that we're
trying to ensure in today and it's not
me that would need the dinghy and the
waders it would be all the people that
are going to live in the new houses that
was the point uh just to go back on
landscape uh John payment you said
earlier that we can condition that as
reserved as of course we can
we did that on the two sites further up
the road
which is why it's really not helpful
that we don't have a picture of that
because we've already done that there we
already conditioned it we already put
all of those measures into place
and the impact I still remained with the
evidence of these eyes is devastating
what you cannot do at Reserve matters is
say oh dear uh we'd rather like a load
of landscaping where you've got that
visibility display for that access which
is precisely what happened on the other
two developments up this road which is
my point we cannot be shown the impact
of this of what we're approving today
not what we're conditioning at Reserve
matters thank you chair
thank you for that councilor Stringer
with that in mind
um is there any way that we can put on a
recommendation that the minimum amount
of um
hedgerowry movement be agreed with the
planning officer would that be helpful
is that possible could we do something
like that can I just maybe I come in on
this one as well
um Bronwyn did you have that essentially
there's two plans that we're talking
about here we've got a we've already got
a removal plan for landscaping is that
correct
I'll just take you back to it on the
presentation very small though Bron I
think it's yeah I'm sorry I don't know
why it's not letting me expand I'll try
that again bear with me a moment so
essentially we already have a plan that
we have conditioned have we not
in our recommendation so we do know what
the
extent of removal will be
in that context that is the so that's
the plan right so that plan shows us
what is proposed to be removed
so is that all the purpley stuff is
going to be removed and all the red
stuff's going to be removed the red
hatching is to be removed so that is
mainly that section along the northern
boundary on Union Road can you just show
it with your little pointer I mean
everything's so minuscule here
there's your little pointer gone
what what this doesn't include at this
stage because it's a reserve matter is
what will go in place of that Hedgerow
so what I was trying to explain in the
presentation was that just because that
hedge is coming out doesn't mean there
will be all hard Landscaping in that
area and no
vegetation can we put something in now
that gives members comfort so we so we
know what's going to be removed we know
that we are looking at Reserve matters
in terms of landscaping that we can find
out what will at that stage what we'll
go back and if that's not good enough we
have the option at that stage to to
increase or sort out that Landscaping
matter we also in addition in this case
which is very unusual to outline we have
a parameters plan effectively for the
landscape area
um so and that I believe we've also
conditioned so if we also go back to the
is it the other plan bombing that is to
be in general Accord with
if I understood that correctly
this is the general accordance with
right okay so registration remove retain
plan the other the other one the context
plan was illustrative
okay but what we do have is a
recommendation from our landscape
advisor
um for a schema art Advanced boundary
planting to be agreed and the um let me
just check the wording and the
recommendation bear with me a second
[Music]
and
um okay so maybe what I'm asking is if
we go to that other plan that shows
roughly where the development will be
would it give members Comfort if we did
say restrict the development to that
General parameter
in respect of the built form area
because if the lens it does that give us
the information
I think it's the one with all the little
the curves on it and the little hoses
you go the other way Bron
that one no no there was another one so
that well that's the landscape context
plan one of course there's another one
that showed where the houses well I
suppose it's the same difference
oh the other one but houses is not going
to indicate the number yeah
but the this is gives context to the
building area and the landscaping area
that are necessary that we have said are
acceptable for the landscape context in
principle for this area
if it would give members more comfort
that this is the likelihood then we
could condition this plan
that's a thought
it's uh Council Stringer has said he
wants to know more in terms of the
understanding now well may I come back
together
basis because that's why we're having
this conversation councilor Stringer
what do you think about that proposal uh
I would say we've done this all before
show me the picture of what we've done
on that same plan it does indicate what
Hopkin homes have done next door in
terms of the sort of where they got to
it also indicates the sort of Master
Plan of children leaves and the
landscape uh intentions towards the end
of the phasing of that particular
development uh now we haven't got to
that yet in terms of the last couple of
phases of children leaves but it is
highly likely that that is where we will
end up on the basis that the 106
agreement for that particular
development has essentially allocated
all of the land of the north as you see
uh to be in Council control as
recreational land
um so I think John I'll leave that
judgment because we're busy telling
members not to discuss other application
I appreciate that and now we're doing it
on this so in terms of this application
it has to be looked at on is Merit
psychologically
thank you okay so who else was
time around um if you'd like to put your
video on and and we'll hear from other
members please cancel custom I think it
might be a hand up that worked
thank you very much Madam chairman um
I'd like to take this opportunity to
approach to um propose approval
of this um application
um did we um say there's already an
advanced boundary um
planting condition in there
um
no no we haven't sorry would you like
that that was something that John was
trying to add with this um slide number
25 wasn't it John
so that there was two suggestions on the
table one is uh We've mentioned that
there will be a scheme of advanced
planting to be agreed
um I I think it's kind of hinted at in
in the conditions before you but it
hasn't been expressly said so it would
be perhaps useful to say it
um that we would be looking for a scheme
of advanced planting in terms of any
landscape scheme that comes forward the
additional thing that I've started to
get into the conversation of here but of
course members need to take this forward
on their own basis is to say that you
could possibly say that the Landscaping
should also Accord to this landscape
context plan that is before you at this
moment in time so that's a secondary
thing if you wish to do that I will
leave that with you well I'll ask
councilor Caston who's just put the
proposal forward would you like that to
add into it yes thank you I think yeah
there's two conditions there um and I'd
like to add both of those to this and
I'd like to um members to discuss that
whether they
um agree with that or not at this stage
well I need a seconder and then they can
all speak to the motion so
for counselor castens
is that counselor Humphries have you put
your hand up yeah I'm sure thank you um
so it's working again now yeah
um so um
listen to all the debate list all all
the arguments for and against
um I will second
um The Proposal
um and yeah I would like to see those
conditions built in please
um definitely to vote on it
um
yeah so I'm going to Second it and just
to report clarification the railway is
one mile away
thank you
uh yeah okay
um anyone else who wants to speak to the
motion please please make either try
your hands and we'll see it or if not a
video and people may have their say
anyone else
anyone else no
okay well in that case then Robert
um or if we can look to the updated
recommendation with those additional
um items added um could you put that in
the voting system for us please Robert
I've been typing away furiously and I
believe that I've got it in there
now so I'll just read it back so that
we're all um clear before so that Mr
pateman G has heard what I've put in as
well for comment so yeah the application
dc20 zero one triple one zero be
approved as detailed in the officer
recommendation with additional
conditions as follows
scheme of advanced planting to be agreed
and Landscaping Accord to learn Accord
to landscape context plan
yeah so let's be for the development to
record in general terms to the landscape
context plan okay
two seconds please
and sorry could you just say that
essentially what we're trying to say is
the developer the condition will be for
the development to Accord to the uh
landscape context plan which was the
plan that was shown to us earlier
okay
yep that's now in there
so that should now if members if we have
sorry chair just to confirm we are ready
to go to the vote with that thank you
very much if you would please thank you
thank you so if members could please go
to the modern.gov app and please press
the plus plus sign in the top right hand
corner
and go on attendance and voting
once you're on attendance of voting if
you scroll down you will see in light
blue color the line where you click on
and make your vote thank you
sorry Robert cancer Stringer here it
won't open okay councilor could would
you like me to take your vote verbally
yes please uh against please thank you
thank you counselor
so chair I've received all votes and
with councilor stringers vote taken
verbally as well that means that it is
four votes four and four votes against
so it is the chairs casting vote
well
I think we've heard all the arguments
for and against and I do think that
um this site will be allocated if not
today tomorrow the next day and shortly
thereafter so I will be voting for the
application to be granted thank you
thank you chair so noted
and if we now take
um
can we come back at half past is that
sufficient time for everyone to have a
suitable break
um
yeah that's fine too yep lovely thank
you very much if we can come back at
half past then thank you
foreign
we're now live again and I will just do
a quick roll call to make sure we're all
back so councilor James carsten present
councilor Peter Gould
present
councilor Kathy Guthrie yes I'm here
councilor Barry Humphries present
councilor Andrew Millen
president councilor Mike Norris
president Professor Andrew Stringer
president and casserole and War boys
present thank you chair we are all here
and I believe um just to check as well
we have the ward members of councilor
Mueller and councilor Carter here as
well
yeah thank you and councilor Carter I
can see you there I can see your picture
yeah right in that case then thank you
very much we'll move on and um I will
now ask Gemma to present um the case of
DC
2004723 full application residential
development of 141 dwellings 49
affordable with Associated access
Landscaping amenity space and parking
site 3C and 3D Lands south of gun cotton
way and I do recall this has been before
as before but in a different format so
thank you very much Gemma off you go
thank you chair good afternoon everybody
I'll just get that up and running
foreign
there we go
hopefully everybody can see that but do
let me know if not
um yep as chair hopefully said this is
the site 3cm 3D landsouth gun Cotton
white in Stone Market uh and again yeah
quickly this has been before members in
the past in a different uh format so
I'll run through that as well for you
all so um
Stone Market hopefully everyone knows
what it is but it's up there on the map
if needs to be and then if we zoom in a
little bit we've got two aspects to the
site we've got
um what is known as 3C and what is known
as 3D which did initially include this
area of land here but that's now been
developed and then we've got Tesco's at
Stone Market here
and again just zooming out slightly so
we've got gun cotton way running along
here this is the a1120 coming through to
the A14 and um Tesco's in Stone Market
at this site here hopefully that's
helpful for navigation purposes
and then yeah just to just confirms with
error 3C and area 3D and the buildings
you can see there were the buildings on
the original planning permission which
um two of which are now complete you've
got um McDonald's and the Costa Coffee
uh the third one not yet complete
expected to be a master's uh Public
House
so again separate sites slightly with
the footpath running through the middle
and that that those are the main
constraints you can see in in green of
the footpath around and through the site
this is the proposed site layout uh
proposed for 141 dwellings
um it's as mentioned earlier got
existing consent on there so if I would
just show the um
layout that what so this is the proposed
layout and the layouts that were
consented hopefully that helps in the
same format obviously put a bit of a gap
in the middle just so we don't block out
any of the um houses on under the plan
but we've got site 3C which had 68
dwellings on it and site 3D which had
the commercial units
and 48 houses so 116 is consented
obviously I've already mentioned the
McDonald's and the Costas have been
built and this consent is extant it's up
and running and similarly here it's
still a live permission so both of those
are currently up and running
[Music]
if I flipped that one so um on the basis
of those previous consents the
development has been considered
acceptable in principle we've accepted
residential development on this site and
that establishes the principle so
essentially the differences between the
proposal are the additional 25 dialings
the additional 25 does increase the
density we're not talking about the
bigger site we're looking at the same
science area so we're looking at an
increase of density from approximately
33 dwellings per hectare to 40.3
dwellings per hectare
this does comply with cs9 which requires
density of at least 30 dwellings per
hectare whilst it then goes on to say at
least 40 dwellings per hectare may be
achieved in sustainable locations in
towns
and to achieve the increase in units The
Proposal reduces the number of larger
houses and proposes further smaller
properties so this is an additional four
one bed properties 13 two bed properties
of which two are Bungalows and 18 three
red properties while we reduce the
number of four beds by ten and there are
no larger properties over and above the
four bed houses
parking is provided to Suffolk County
Council standards some triple parking is
proposed but this is where it's in
excess of Standards so it I think we can
hopefully just say it's quite small
we've got two spaces in the garage
behind but these are three bed houses
where we need two parking spaces so the
Extra Spaces over and above standard and
not being considered unacceptable
foreign
to the design of the houses the previous
consent one was in a New England style
and the other arts and crafts whereas
this brings the two different parts of
the science together with a similar
style and Design
so this is looking through 3D and across
the edge essentially The View up from
the footpath that runs through here
and then view D at the bottom from the
edge of the site looking slightly down
the hill we'll see that as I've come to
the site photos and again elevation C
looking essentially through the site
and then finally this is a the
essentially Frontage of the site onto
gun cotton way
I have got all the elevations in there
just so I thought it'd be helpful to run
through but I'll go through fairly
quickly essentially some of the
units are the same style we'll see we've
got about three different um plans for
this Baker style but they use different
brick details different materials and
different porches to create a different
character area across the site
so we'll see same house design but
different portraits and different brick
features particularly evident and again
a third Style on that one as well so
I'll run through the remainder fairly
quickly but again we can see we start to
see different porches and different
window Styles we used
this is when the Bungalow style as I
mentioned we've got two two bedroom
Bungalows proposed
again
just those slight differences in styles
used to differentiate areas through the
site
these are all in members bundles if if
I'm going too quickly
and then we get on to the two blocks of
flats we've got uh block a which is on
site 3D and
Block B which is on site 3C I'll just
point them out for you on the layout
members so this is
um
block a on site 3DS is this building in
here and Block B on site 3 C is this
this block here
there are very similar locations to
those that were previously permitted and
not dissimilar designs we have gone
through some amendments on those to try
and ensure that uh the bulk amassing is
uh
improved by the use of materials and
we've used those to split them if I go
back up you can see we've got different
materials used to help break those up
and again also using the roof space as
well to keep the heights minimum but I
said they are very similar to those that
were previously permitted
if I move on to the site photos
um we've got we've just come into gun
cotton wave from the a1120 behind us
Tesco's and the roundabouts Tesco's is
on our right with the Costa and
McDonald's on our left here access by
going off into this slip Road
[Music]
and we're down at the slip road we can
see Costa in here completing up and
running and then we come down to the
Tesco roundabout where there is an
access into the site just off to the
left
again sorry that probably doesn't show
anything too different but but that's
there and then again coming down towards
that roundabout
and looking back up
towards the 1120 Main roundabout
and then this is the Tesco roundabout we
just start to see the site where it's
been fenced off to the left
and looking in on there you can see
where the development has been commenced
on that site as it stands
and then looking across uh essentially
down into stone market we've got the
footpath that runs down through here and
then the site 3D is across this part
and then again looking down onto what's
already been commenced
and this is the footpath and cycleway
that runs through the site so we've got
one site to our left is site 3D and site
3C to our right
and again looking back up from the
footpath we just see Costa to the top
left and I said the
um development's already taken place on
the extent consent
and then looking to the other side so
we've got the gun cotton way up here to
our right with the commercial units and
again looking down into State Market
that way
and then we're looking up here on the
existing properties on Cedars Park and
again looking up to those ongoing cotton
way
and then finally you can we're looking
from the top of the hill with the
employment Commissioners behind us site
3C to our right and site 3D coming up
here as we get towards Costa
and again just looking sort of the
across the road from the site
[Music]
and back up towards the commercial units
okay so um the proposal has been
considered acceptable in principle we've
accepted that under the extant consents
essentially the difference between that
um
consented and proposed is additional 25
units it does increase the density but
this has not been found to be to an
unacceptable level and remains in
compliance with cs9 it does also have an
added benefit of a number of smaller
units
um which are considered to be
appropriate in this location given all
of that the proposal is considered to be
acceptable with terms of these amended
units and the increase in density and
not to result in harm and so subject to
the section 106 and conditions that
you're on page is 450 to 452 the
recommendation is for approval thank you
chair
thank you Gemma um do members have some
questions for the officer please we'll
try the hands up function see if it
works
anybody
if that's not working does anybody want
to sort of put their video up in case
they wish to speak no
ah who's that no
that was Gemma yourself sorry uh Roland
yes
I'm waving wildly
um yeah just some question uh as I
spotted some cycle paths on your
photographs could you just confirm
whether these cycle routes all joined up
into stone market so people can travel
easily into stoma to get to the railway
station yeah of course that's exactly
what it does it's coming through here if
you hopefully you can see my mouse on
there so it comes down through the sites
um and and links up um I think it's well
used at the moment from my experiences
being on site in the area it's a popular
link down in Stone Market
thank you thank you councilor any other
counselors wish to ask any questions
no right
um
in that case then
we have
we don't
have a representative from the parish as
I see it an objector or a supporter
so we move on to the applicant which
would be Laura Dudley Smith and you have
three minutes to address the committee
and Alex savorski also available to
answer questions thank you
three minutes and our officer will time
you thank you thank you good afternoon
members I'm Laura Dudley Smith with
Justin Parker strasen Parker or the
planning Consultants acting on behalf of
belway homes for the revised scheme
proposed for Cedars Park Parcels 3D and
3D
Fairway homes are a successful house
Builder delivering and building out a
number of sites across Suffolk and Essex
you will be aware of the recent
permissions granted for 65 homes in
Hawley and 190 in Whitton which give an
indication of belway's commitment to
high quality design and layout as well
as their overall role in the delivery of
homes and contribution to the local
economy in mid-suffolk in particular
your office's presentation just now has
provided details of the existing
planning consents that have been granted
for these Parcels both of the
permissions are extent and deliverable
this new application seeks to retain the
principles established through these
permissions but alongside an adjusted
housing mix which will allow for the
delivery of smaller homes better suited
to the current market and needs
identified in the most most recent
strategic housing market assessment as
agreement officers the replacement of a
number of the larger four bed units with
smaller one two and three bed homes will
see an overall increase of 25 units
across the two sites eight of these
additional homes will be affordable
ensuring ongoing compliance with the
relevant local policies the overall
density of the sites will still reflect
those delivered across Cedars Park and
the nearest Parcels on the opposite side
of gun cotton way in particular the
delivery of these two Parcels will also
ensure the provision of footpaths along
the south side of gun cotton way to
completely existing pedestrian and
cycleway network around the area the
scheme will continue to deliver parking
in full accordance with Suffolk County
Council standards and notably removes
all incidences of triple parking which
had previously been approved a much
higher proportion of parking is also
provided on plot as opposed to in large
parking courts as previously
electric vehicle charging will will be
provided to all homes with on plot
parking and ducting will will be
provided to the shared areas we have
worked closely with officers to ensure
the scheme continues to meet all
relevant local planning policies and are
pleased to have no outstanding
objections for Miss suffolk's technical
consultants including ecology
Landscaping Refuge environmental health
and strategic housing we've engaged
directly with Suffolk County Council to
ensure the scheme remains acceptable in
terms of Highways and drainage also
feedback received from Stone Market Town
Council and Cedars Park residence
Association has also seen a redesign of
the apartment blocks and a two meter
reduction in their height the scheme
will provide additional civil monies
proportionate to the additional floor
space to be delivered and the site's
reassessment from by Suffolk
infrastructure has also seen a request
for section 106 contributions on top of
sill to be increased by nearly four
times we do hope that you will be able
to agree with your officer's
recommendation to ensure the delivery of
this site and its continued contribution
to mid-suffolk's five-year housing land
Supply alongside the other associative
benefits thank you very much for your
time
thank you very much and before I go to
other members I've got a couple of
questions actually
um you say that it complies with all
policies I thought it was 40 per hectare
and yet this is 40.3 is that correct
the density is
um yes yeah so slightly over yeah yes
sorry chair would you mind for
interrupting it does say at least 40
dwellings per hectare
um
okay
um and you also mentioned um you've got
rid of the tandem parking but I believe
there are didn't I hear 18 three bedroom
properties have three tandem parking
yeah so I mean as Jim as Gemma mentioned
in her presentation the the what are
what could be seen as
um instances or triple tandem parking
now are where effectively only two
spaces are required for those units so
it's basically two spaces and a garage
um which could be used for parking if if
wanted so it's uh it's a space in excess
of the parking standards that will be
required otherwise okay and the other
thing is are these smaller homes within
the standards that we require the homes
to be built these days
so they're all of the little boas
um house types are ndss complaint yes
thank you sorry members I just thought
I'd ask those questions down and I've
got them written anyone else want to ask
questions
cancer string
thank you chair uh uh three three points
you said you're going to be providing
electric charging points you'll be
providing the cabling for it and not the
charging point or the charging Point as
well
um yes so I believe it's the um for the
on plot units it's yeah it's the cabling
which are then taken out to kind of
capital so so you won't be providing
electric charging points you'll provide
the ability to install one
um yes yes okay that's fine how are you
going to address at the moment at most
lunch times the access off the 11 uh the
11 20 I think is into the site is queued
up to the roundabout uh are there any
proposals to uh add to that or how do
how do we mitigate that uh the other
little thing uh mppf paragraph 150 uh
where B we need to help reduce
Greenhouse emissions so it's location
orientation and design how are we
heating these
yeah
I just answer that question though if
that's okay yes yeah um so so in regards
so okay
um so in answer to your your first or
your second Point uh councilor um we
will be looking to bring gas or uh gas
boilers onto the scheme
um primarily because the infrastructure
is already installed and the contracts
were previously agreed before we had an
interest on the site
um I think it's worth noting that we um
the boilers that we'll be looking at we
sort of knocks emissions of 40
milligrams per kilo an hour or less so a
high efficient boiler
um and your second point about the
um highways issues
um we've been working tirelessly with
highways about
congestion and it was it was the thought
or the approach was that the the impacts
on the infrastructure was negligible
um with only an in marginal increase of
13 vehicle movements and consequence of
the uplifting houses on site
take it into debate you've got you've
got the answer to your question if
you've got another question go with the
question oh well I didn't sorry okay I
didn't get the answer sorry you didn't
get the answer you asked about
mitigating no no no the yes the the
stacking of traffic I I wasn't I wasn't
asking how much this site would add to
that I was asking how you would access
this site if there is already queuing in
that road up to the roundabout it's
already there that question fair
question yeah and I might be able to add
a little bit more of that my my
understanding at the moment is that um
the situation has recently weeks been
sort of exacerbated by the um current
kind of covid-19 secure arrangements for
the establishments on the roundabout and
so I think the cost of for example and
the same
um I expect for McDonald's because
they're operating a drive-through only
service
um it has obviously kind of intensified
how how that's those sites are being
used
um obviously it therefore makes uh sort
of it makes it difficult to gauge if
that's going to be an ongoing issue or
not
um but all I say is that you know the
modeling that's been undertaken for um
for the site in respect of the
additional 25 units um has taken into
account
um the kind of existing Baseline
conditions and yeah the additional units
aren't excited to
um worse than anything
um Beyond existing conditions and I
think to be fair it's outside this
planning app education
um you know you're it's out of your
control when other people are operating
um Andrew was there another question or
have you had sufficient answers to your
questions
I've had an answer sorry I've had an
answer thank you yeah okay thank you and
um I'm presuming by the fact Andrew
you're there councilor Mellon if you
would like your question please do ask
um yes thank you chair
um it's a question for the um Alex from
from belway
um I'm just um just following up on the
question about um heating these
properties with gas and I'm looking at
the bellway uh environment policy where
it talks about using a range of
renewable energy Technologies such as
solar panels flow two voltaic panels air
and ground Source heat pumps doesn't
seem to mention gas in there
I think councilor melon the uh the
answer was that it was already on
on Mr Swarovski had already given you
that answer so I think that's for debate
rather than further reasoning as to why
it's not in his
uh paper yeah he's not in his head yeah
thank you any further questions for um
the applicants is that Council of War
boys or have you had your
question no counselor Norris you have a
question
yes thank you thank you uh within the
papers from our public realm officer he
States it's disappointing the new formal
areas of public open space or play areas
associated with this phase of
development existing play provision may
not have been designed to accommodate
the additional use that will now what's
the question please cancel yeah well I'm
coming to it says the location of play
areas on the far side is a busy arterial
route through the site is an added risk
my question is why were there no play
areas within the actual phase itself
because it means children crossing a
road to get to a play area otherwise
thank you so so the provision of
publication open on this public open
space on the site is reflective of what
was provided on the two previous
consents at that stage for those
concerns I understand it was considered
acceptable
um in respect of the existing provision
in the local vicinity and also the
connections available through The
Pedestrian and cycleway network around
Cedars Park so there's obviously
existing open space directly to the
south of the site and there's also the
kind of the more formal Recreation and
Community facilities further north
within the wider Cedars part scheme and
as I mentioned in the presentation
obviously the
uh the development will include the
provision of footpaths Along gun cosm
away so that there's direct connections
to those existing um connectivity
Networks
thank you for that any further questions
please for the applicant
no I think we're there thank you very
much indeed thank you
um sorry it came yes we're coming onto
the ward members
but coming on to the ward members now
um so I don't know which of you are
going to speak first I'll let you choose
that yourselves can I go first please
yes you can and so Ward member counselor
Dave Muller thank you thank you very
much chair
um
since this application uh came uh came
up before previously we we totally
accept that planning permission has been
granted for 125 properties across the
two sites and what I'm going to look at
is the positives and negatives of this
latest application the positives I'd
like to thank belway for redesigning the
Flats on both 3C and 3D I do like the
new new sort of um
um design of those I support the
archeology investigations as mentioned
in the conditions
um there was quite a lot of archeology
found close by and field Fair close
which is about 150 meters away from this
particular site so I think it's really
important that that is one of the
conditions
I would also like to commend the report
that was in the actual planning portal
from Southern ecological Solutions
limited which is produced in September
20 regarding the ecology on site and
this particular site particularly 3C has
got tremendous Wildlife biodiversity
Etc right around this site and I must
admit that paper looked at that in in
very great details so I really
appreciate that
um so that that was excellent
um good to see the proposed indicative
glazing and ventilation to meet the
requirements to mitigate the noise and
also a noise barrier around some of the
gardens I fully support that as well the
site as has already been pointed out is
well served by cycle and footpaths but I
would point out what Laura has just said
about the play area
um below site 3C this is actually a
balancing Pond which is currently
completely fenced off because it
contains invasive
um weed which will not be removed for
several years it has to be removed in
stages and a lot of people used to fish
on that pond as a recreation thing
they're no longer able to do that
because they say it's completely fenced
off
they I fully support the cabling to the
houses regarding electrical vehicle
points but I would point out that
Tesco's have just recently installed
some electrical vehicle charging points
on their site
totally support the smaller number of
the the smaller units particularly The
Bungalow so there is generally a
shortage of Bungalows on the site and
the fact there will be a slight increase
in in affordable homes that's the
positives I've also got a few comments
about negatives that the report actually
mentions
um an early years provider on the
Chilton uh Chilton filter State as I
understand it this has not yet been
built there are actually two early years
providers already on Cedar's Park one
within less than five minutes walk from
this site and the other one at Cedars
Park Community Center which is about a
10 minute walk from this site
the report quite rightly points out that
there are no spare capacity at Cedars
Park school that is correct
um children would need to travel to
Trinity School which is um about a
couple of miles away and would have this
would have to be done by car as there is
no public transport available to that
school
there are bus stops in fact there's a
bus stop just at the top of
plot 3C but we've got no proper bus
service there's approximately four buses
a day
it's a very poor bus service very poor
times very infrequent uh and and I
cannot see that being reintroduced in
the foreseeable future
uh what character Nora says about the
children's play areas is absolutely
right the nearest play area of decent
sized play area is allocated off of
avasek gardens which would mean that
children and adults would have to cross
gun cotton way which at times is an
extremely busy road
so therefore I totally agree there
should be a play area on that particular
site
I am concerned about the triple parking
um page 443 of the report mentions
triple parking on some plots a power of
2.5 to be precise however the Beltway
flyer which I've received says no triple
parking at all so we've just been told
there is some triple parking and I can
assure members that there's quite a bit
of this type of parking on Cedar's Park
people don't use it they either park on
the pavement I've got that example just
down the road from where I am at this
moment in time and it does cause a lot
of consternation amongst residents where
they can't walk on the pavement because
they don't use their double or triple
parking
I was very concerned about the uh the
photographs of gun cotton way
particularly between the roundabout at
the top of the a1120 and the roundabout
by Tesco's which will also be one of the
entrances to site 3D this is actually
extremely busy these days and I've had
many residents have approached me and
said it's taken them between 10 and 20
minutes to actually cross the road there
and I've actually encountered that
myself
um the fact that McDonald's and Costa
Coffee are applying covered regulations
at the moment so they're not having
opening the cafe I can assure members
that even when the cafe is open it's
still incredibly busy there and this is
not just at rush hour at times it's
during other times of the day there was
actually a child who was actually
knocked down on that piece of road
across from um Costa sorry with
McDonald's soon after it opened in
August 19. unfortunately the child was
not badly injured we did actually ask if
a road safety audit could be undertaken
at that time we assured that there would
be but as far as I'm aware none has ever
been done and with more traffic the road
will become increasingly dangerous and
that is one of the major concerns that
residents keep saying to me there's just
too much traffic on that they are really
concerned about that
there are no local dentists taking
current NHS patients in Stone Market
so although we accept that this
particulars were both sites are actually
in the in the emerging local plan and
believe me the existing local Club
Market we feel that an increase of 21.5
percent of properties is completely
unacceptable
um for this site so although we we don't
object to planning as such I cannot
support the application for the
additional houses I think it's too many
and that's the feedback that I have been
getting for local residents thank you
chair
that was very helpful to run through it
like that thank you very much indeed
very fulsome
um do members have questions uh for
councilor Mueller if you would allow
that uh councilor Carter if we can just
have questions for councilor Muller
please councilman Muller
um do members have questions is that um
a question from you councilor warboys
have you got your hand up
not sure looks like councilor caston's
amazing sorry my hand isn't up chairman
right if counselor again I can't see
them again I'm so sorry councilor
Castleton you have a question please
thank you very much um yeah councilor
Muller Could you um just point out where
there's some fenced off
Ponders
yes if we if we um if Gemma if we could
kind of have the photograph which shows
site 3C yeah just bear with me two sex
thank you
it's actually um it's that's exactly
where it is
um it was fenced off because there was a
Japanese Primrose weed which is
apparently is incredibly invasive and
they're trying to avoid it getting into
the local Rivers
um it's Crest Nicholson still own that
part of the site and they are
responsible for the fencing around it
and also for clearing so put it out
again because I'm blow devices down here
no here if this is the one we're talking
about this one
there's a big pond down here that's the
one
here no here that one yeah yeah that's
weird that's the one that's and that's
likely to be fenced off for several
years because I had correspondents with
crescent Nicholson about a month ago
following up some complaints and
residents of why it has been fenced off
again and uh it's due to the fact we
think from local residents emptying
their fish ponds with goldfish there's
plenty of goldfish in that pond and
accidentally or whatever putting this
dangerous weed into that particular Pond
and I know the environment agency are
also involved with this as well thank
you
thank you for pointing that out
um and any other question uh councilor
Caston
no um sorry madam chair um I left my
hand up yeah okay
um councilor Humphreys you have you have
it in for um councilor Muller please
I'm sure thank you uh Cassie Miller it's
um just going back to that map actually
just so good at my head where's the play
area in relation to that pawn please the
play the play there is no actual play
area by that pond it's just literally a
cycle stroke footpath around that pawn
there's no play equipment there
um it's just a pond where you could
actually walk around the pond it's a
grass there around the pond which is
much Wildlife there but there's no
actual play area there at all all right
sorry I was getting confused I thought
you mentioned it was there was a play
area
okay all right yeah sorry okay so happy
the player the newest play area is is
basically off of abbaset gardens which
is what we call the Village Green area
the really large area which are bats gun
cotton way at the top end about a couple
of hundred meters away and creating Road
East
thank you that's that's actually helped
me in debate thank you thank you very
much thank you
any further questions for councilor
Mueller
thank you very much councilor Muller and
now councilor Carter your view on
everything please
yes I I do love going after uh
councilman it's gone through three pages
I've just been blind through with my
report so that's just brilliant
um I have been popping up on and off
with my hand up and my head up so ask
some questions but so I'll just go ahead
oh I'm so sorry if you have question I
literally can't see these hands up what
what is the question before you know
it's been answered by a councilor
regarding there's only four uh buses
that are a day I wanted to ask um if the
officers could tell us exactly how many
of them are adapted and I can answer
that question is is one adapted bus
Which you'll get through every two days
for um for Mobility for wheelchairs uh
they need review companies are
um have signed any agreements to provide
um these accessible travel
um regards the access between
this area well firstly I'll do the same
as a councilman of garden V positives
and I would surprise myself and others
to say that in general I don't dislike
the proposal for building Footprints are
quite sensible quite attractive with
facades adapted to fit those that would
um see elsewhere and stay foreign
development
and opposed to previous past
Fabrications appears well suited to a
Development Area it's
not Greenfield it's not particularly
beautiful at the moment where those
locations are
um however I do have some concerns with
connectivity uh with the rest of Stone
Market without the bus bus link
you're having to walk or travel to to
Central Stone Market to travel
there is bats lovely and it is a lovely
bike route that goes through
um
um quite a large downhill area
a mobility scooter battery might be able
to make it down a bus route
I mainly not bus route but down by
footpath they cannot make it up I've
killed two scooters trying to get up
that way
um which means makes leafleting
wonderful
um so try and get up that route it's not
possible we're on certain that certain
movie devices uh that leaves you have
two other options you either go cross B
rather busy Railway Bridge and let me
tell you if you have two scooters going
different directions on the same side of
a part pavement if that makes it a bit
tricky especially if one of you's got to
go into the roads and Roads currently
being used
uh the other option is going around the
houses or around the station as it were
and going the long way which as
councilor has answered previously
regarding the uh we have a lot of issues
with pavement parking and when you are
trying to transverse around it and
you're either going through a narrow
narrow pathway and find yourself blocked
by a car if you've got a four mile per
hour scooter you don't have the option
of dropping off the curb to go around it
you have to reverse all the way and
that's not exactly ideal or possible
some places so on that area
um if you do have a if you are lucky
enough to have one which is it goes to
eight miles per hour and you can go on
the road
I wouldn't advise doing that because if
you become face to face with one-way
traffic and a bit of a car who's got
priority you've got move out away
so it makes it quite a difficult route
to transverse going from this area which
is a lovely area it's lovely by itself
but to get with the stone markets you're
cut off
and it is okay we are served nicely by
matescos we do have the Costa and we do
have McDonald's and whilst every little
helps you one can't live on caffeine and
smacky D's alone
so I'd if we could address these and to
also address the the issue with the
climbing but not climbing but the play
area
I wouldn't want my daughter having to
cross the distance to get from there to
the nearest play area I certainly
wouldn't want to do it myself and I
wouldn't want my wife and to walk it
either so if I was looking for
why I look at developments I Look to
somewhere that I'd like to be happy to
live myself and unfortunately as things
are I wouldn't want to place myself in
that area
so thank you
thank you for that councilor Carter I
suppose really my question would have
been um probably better served by um in
some respects by councilor Mueller but I
ask you this question is on if you're
living on the other side of the road if
you see what I mean with the already
built properties
um you'd still would you still have that
same problem of traversing down the
hills I know the area roughly to get
into stowmarket would you still have the
same problem with a Mobility Scooter
getting down into up over the bridge and
near where the b m is and all that sort
of thing you still have that same
problem you still have that same problem
yes I I know we can't we have to look at
just this developments regardless
then you've been helpful to answer it
that's very useful if members would like
to offer piggybacks from down the street
I'd happily I'll accept it but that's no
I I understand your difficulties and
it's very interesting to hear it from
your point of view so thank you for the
input on that do other members have
questions for councilor Carter please is
that councilor Humphries have you got
your hand up there
was that an old one I don't know whether
these hands up yeah
um anyone else have any questions for
counselor Carter there please
councilor Humphreys and old hands how
rude
yeah
um thank you for that and thank you for
the input from everybody so um I think
we've moved on now
um let's see where we are we're open to
date now then who wants to let's go with
councilor cast and again let's go A to Z
with these wretched hands up aren't
working I apologize
thank you madam chairman I think we've
got to be careful of distractions on
this application we have got existing
consents on the site so I think for me
this comes down to
will the extra houses the extra
dwellings on that site make a difference
we we've got consent for existing
dwellings
um in my opinion
the um it's more of the sort of houses
that I want to see I want to see starter
homes I want to see people um out of
rented accommodation owning their own
home these houses are much more suitable
for that
um so I think a lot of the issues and I
do feel for a lot of the issues that are
brought up but with existing consents on
this
um area I I don't think that they are
massively relevant to what we're talking
about here what I would like to um see
though is um with those smaller houses
with the um with with the potential for
new um first-time buyers coming in
um most a lot of them will have children
and I think this site needs even if it's
just a modest play area on site
so that the um say that those um those
families don't have to cross the road
don't have to um go far they can they
can just go out onto their own area I
don't know if that's possible on here
but I would accept the extra houses on
there the um the change to um design
um but I would say that the there is an
area there that could have a modest a
playground on it and I'd I'd like that
to be considered
thank you and thank you for that
councilor Kirsten and can I just ask
Gemma on the previous application was
there a child's play area with just a
swing and a seesaw or something like
that
um Gemma if you could just um
no there weren't there weren't any
proposed on the previous I can bring the
layout back up if that would help
briefly just before councilor girl
speaks yes please just a quick to see
sorry I don't know what happened
is the PowerPoint come up yeah yeah oh
sorry it's it's not showing on my screen
if I go back up
to the
um
I am thank you I am having trouble with
this one so I'll stop sharing and I'll
try again because that's not what I want
to it's it's gone right share again
sorry chair
right
yeah it's not it's not coming up as
there it is
waiting for you to pop that up can I
hear from councilor Gould um while you
try and get what we we would like to
look at
um
okay uh chat with you yeah Gemma if you
just let counselor Gould speaker then of
course no problems green yeah cancel the
gold yep thank you very much uh chair
and I'm start by
um especially my gratitude to uh to
councilor Mueller who uh with his
characteristic uh fairness I thought
um but brought some understanding
certainly for me he brought some
understanding to the nature of this
development and some of the discussions
that been going on and also thanks to
council Carter understand because uh
councilman is so thorough I can
understand you having to put a line
through some of what you were intending
to say but is so often the case
um I appreciate the insights that you
bring uh to us when we're when we're
considering the applications uh the as
it's been said uh
um standing uh approvals in relation to
this site and it it does boil down to
the question about the the additional uh
houses and and again I agree the point
about uh having homes small all the
homes accessible to those that are
moving into who need that kind of
Housing and are moving into the market I
think that's absolutely uh to to to be
welcome uh I also agree councilor
castens uh concern to see some play area
provision uh give it given the uh the
the the occupancy of those houses uh I
think that would be very much needed and
if there's a way of doing that I'd like
to see it thank you very much Jeff
thank you
um Gemma have you got anything there
that sort of
sort of value this one this is these are
the consented schemes across the site so
not including a play area we've got the
area through the center of the site
which is
um the attenuation basis
so that that's a batch of the itinerary
so it does leave us with that small area
there
um on one side isn't it it was the other
side that I think is the concerns yeah
and I mean a very small area in in there
but I'm it's on the back of the houses
whether that would be appropriate for
play
I don't know and it is for me that
moment of do the 25 in themselves need
the play area versus that approved
consent if I if I flip back to it so
that's the difference between the two
yeah
okay let's move on with the debate and
see where we go with it but um I I think
um I know which way people will be um
favoring Improvement
um two less houses and one more playing
area or something however
um can no I don't think any cancer
Carter anymore thank you
um I would like to now move on please to
um councilor Humphreys if you would
please
I'm sure thank you
um yeah good debate so far um I was
originally concerned about the density I
sort of still am but I do understand it
now it's been explained about the up to
amount and I also welcome the increase
of one and two bedroom houses because
that is important and as councilor Gould
highlighted it is definitely needed so
so I welcome that I also welcome
reduction in the heights of the the
blocks themselves and the good use of
the roof line so so that's all good news
and also the wiring for the provision of
electric vehicle charging points uh yeah
it'd be fantastic to have them fitted
but they cost money but there are grunts
available and one of them is the
electric vehicle home charge scheme so
people want to fit them representatively
they can because the wiring's there so
that's good news
um
the play area side of it I do get but
there's more to it than that it's about
the road it's not about the play area
it's about the children crossing the
road and as councilman Muller um
actually stated it's also about adults
Crossing that road it is extremely busy
um and at times Vehicles travel down
there fast there is no crossing point
but it's not about going to the play
area it's about going to Tesco's it's
about going to the school it's about
going to the preschool it's about going
to the cedis community center there are
lots of reasons for crossing that road
and I think that outside of this
planning meeting those Ward counselors
might want to start canvassing their
Suffolk County Council counterparts to
push for a Crossing along that road and
I think they get loads of support but I
think that's outside this planning
meeting because we can only really
discuss what's in front of us and as
councilor Caston already stated
permissions already been granted okay so
it's not going to go away we're just
looking at really the changes are we not
um what else have we got the good thing
about this place I get the bus uh that's
a a real pain you'd expect for such a
large estate that there'd be more bus
um bus routes and more regularity of
those bus routes and again that's
something that should be conversed
outside this meeting but that said this
is close to the town it has got good
routes into the town for pedestrians and
cyclists and they're well used already
so this is gonna it's gonna continue in
the future but I do get counselor
Carter's points about the slope and the
fact that we've
um electric
um sort of wheelchairs Etc it can be
difficult to make that Journey there and
back and that's also true of the elderly
with their electric vehicles so it's not
just for people with disabilities it's
also the elderly and we've got an we've
got an increasing number of those in
society but again
I think that's outside this planning
application but it is a point of note
but what is good about it well it's
close to the A14 and people might say
that's terrible but it's not because
people need to travel to work so it's a
quick access to that work unfortunately
a longer busy road uh it's close to the
Gateway 14 project which uh if it comes
along May produce more jobs for the
people that might actually live on this
on this development and of course it's
close to the railway it's easily
accessible by foot or cycle and that can
take you to work or elsewhere so I think
the location is fine
um I was conservative density I think
that's gone because I think what
supersedes it is the fact that it's not
outside of limits and we've got an
increase in one or two bedroom houses
um so therefore so far
um even though I've listened to some of
the debate I will listen to the rest of
the debate but Surfer on Monday for
approval
thank you for that councilor Humphries
now councilor Carter you have got your
hand up but I wouldn't really actually
invite you in though because we are into
the debate is that an old hand as it
were and if you could put it down please
because we're into debating now
so um I will move on
to
counselor melon please
yeah thank you chair
um I don't have a lot to say on this I
find myself rather conflicted about this
site it's um
it's clearly you know within Stone
Market
um and and has access to some Services
um but it is quite a long way from
others is is actually quite a step to
the the Town Center
um so although you've got Tesco Costa
McDonald's and Screwfix nearby
um it's quite a way to the doctor's
surgery to a post office and the train
station a fair distance as well
um
I I absolutely get um uh councilor
Humphrey's point about the crossing
required on on on gun cotton way I mean
that that road I don't know why it just
seems to have been designed so that
people can slalom around those
roundabouts at a fairly um a fairly good
Pace
um so you know I Echo his his um call
for a a safe crossing point there
um I I am concerned about belway putting
gas boilers in I will make that point
because it's not in their environment
policy but I won't labor that point and
I'll listen to the debate further thank
you
thank you very appropriate comments
there thank you very much councilor
Mellon councilor Norris
thank you madam chair uh well yes
obviously reservation about the lack of
proper provision for play as I've
already mentioned uh there is another
area actually that
um I'd like to raise but I'm at the foot
of page 426.
Suffolk Wildlife Crossroads some
comments about
biodiversity
and they go on to page four to seven and
they have put certain recommendations in
there we don't appear to have reflected
them very strongly in the conditions on
fourth page four five one it does
mention a biodiversity method statement
to be agreed but I'd like that to be
strengthened more in line with what the
wildlife trust are
suggesting apart from that I have
nothing further to say at this point and
I'll listen to the rest of the debate
thank you
councilor Norris and now we have
counselor Stringer if you would please
uh thank you chair uh we did a little
bit of History earlier about uh what
happened in this area and we've got
consents that we can't go backwards
there is a reason why there's not a
pedestrian crossing here the reason for
there's no pedestrian Crossing is the
south side of this road was going to be
capture employment use it was not deemed
that that would be used for housing and
now of course it has we then have the
problem that we don't have the crossings
so why on Earth they weren't conditioned
in the past I have no idea but we can't
go backwards all we can do is go
forwards
uh I do have a number of concerns about
this you can normally get greater
densities when you get into towns and
certainly cities every day of those
densities can go up
but just because you've got a consent
doesn't necessarily mean that you should
then just wave a a a a condensing of
that and adding more uh
certainly from that area of play if you
if it wasn't if it didn't seem very good
and and terribly acceptable to have a
certain number of houses with no play
area
why should you add to it without any
play area because I'm surprised there's
no mention here from the police the
police normally flag up about trying to
design out crime and the ability to uh
conduct crime and I've just got a
horrible feeling that if there's no play
area here the play area will become a
skate park that where people park for
McDonald's or Costa you know then you
won't have to cross a busy road you you
can just nip there and and meet your
friends and do everything you want to do
and I don't think that's going to be
necessarily uh terribly sustainable so
the other thing I have a problem with I
can't see anywhere where are bin people
have said they can actually access the
bins
because we've condensed it now it's a
lot tighter on site I certainly can't
get Freighters in here on on with my uh
with my ruling we already spend a
fortune trying to get rubbish collection
for an existing housing on Cedar spot
because we just physically can't get
Freighters into part of that site and I
haven't seen the response we've got a
condition that says there'll be bin
collection points well where are they
going to be on the on the roundabout
outside Tesco's I don't know because
there's an awful lot of these roads
where you just physically cannot get a
freighter up so if we want to add more
housing where you just can't collect the
bins or they end up in a big Heap
outside someone's house fine but that's
not what we're supposed to do when we
when we let go housing we're supposed to
design it to make it better not just
make it worse so I accept that there's
approval here of housing which was never
planned in the first place I get that
there's some challenges there we
probably could redress but when you've
got that pinch point I feel really
reluctant to add to that because all
you're doing is you're just going to
exacerbate a problem you've already got
and we've got that issue of the stacking
of the traffic uh and and we're being
told it's only 25 extra yeah but these
haven't been built yet so actually the
increase from what you see at the moment
won't just be 25 it'll be all of them
um so I have to say I I have some issues
with increasing the density without a
lot of those reassurances made thank you
chair
thank you councilor councilor War boys
please
yes thank you chair I I find myself in
agreement with uh what has been said
before
I think Council Humphries and Council
Miller or both summed it up
uh I am very concerned about the lack of
amenity the lack of a play area
I think
um there are problems for pedestrian
safety that have been described
uh in detail Crossing done cotton way
um
and the increase in traffic and the
congestion at the roundabout
um we are proposing on Gateway 14 a sort
of quite a major
uh employment site which is also going
to be accessed in that roundabout so
this is going to be a problem that's
going to get worse in the foreseeable
future and I think there needs to be
some thought about mitigationing
a little bit
uh my main thing hasn't really been
discussed and
I'm actually quietly appalled that the
proposal is to Heap this uh development
by gas
this is
four years before gas boilers are going
to be banned
and I think it's contrary to uh
sustainability and energy strategy
um I've looked at uh Peter chisel's
comments and those got no
objection
it does us that any
that our strategy requires the applicant
to indicate the retrofit
sorry retrofit measures and include an
estimate of the retrofit costs now I
think this
installation of gas boilers is going to
saddle the householders with retrofit
costs in order to achieve Net Zero
carbon emissions by 2050. uh that is our
strategy and
I'd like to see this put into uh
if possible
into
um
our recommendations and that alternative
uh sources of eating are fitted
thank you
thank you for that counselor um Gemma
can I just ask on the previous
application
um we accepted that gas was there and my
understanding is we don't have a policy
to stop fitting of gas boilers anyway
and as the applicant explained they
already had that um in you know when
they they took over the land
um so Gemma can you confirm that the
previous ones were um allowing gas yeah
absolutely it was not a specification on
that previous consent that they couldn't
have gas and that was the expectation I
believe at that time obviously things
have moved slightly on with the climate
emergency and the pressure to consider
that but but no in terms of the existing
one they could be built with gas boilers
exactly yeah okay so um just listening
to the debate and everybody's points of
view all very valid
um when I first looked at this um I must
admit I was a bit disappointed um with
the extra number of houses and then we
heard that you know the bigger ones were
dropped off and there are smaller ones
and I listened to councilor Cass Austin
and earlier are the members who said
that the extra starter homes are
important for people to get on that
ladder and and in a pretty good location
I would think
um but I'm I'm also nervous that there
is no play area provision I mean you
know how much space do you need for a
swing and a seesaw and and just a little
seat for mum to sit with the kids or
something or children I should say so
I'm wondering whether really rather than
we keep going around in circles here
there is a principle of development has
been approved but I wonder if we might
defer this and ask the officer to go
away to see if they can perhaps reduce
um I don't know a couple of houses to
give that play area to give Comfort to
members that whilst we won't get
everything we want out of it we would
get something a little more amenable
um and I mean talking about the Crossing
yeah very valid points I mean if you
looked at one of those photographs and I
think I'm writing saying if you go
around that Tesco roundabout that any
great speed you probably lose your sump
because the the wear on that road is
absolutely appalling and again the wear
on the road into the sides um look
pretty lumpy and bumpy so
um you know maybe there can be something
looked at
um regarding
persuading highways that there might be
a need for um a Crossing there but
that's outside of this application but
that could be something that could be
looked at but I'm wondering if we should
defer it um to look for some children's
play area albeit small
um so if I put that proposal on the
table would I have a seconder to it
yes Mike Norris I'd be pleased to Second
it I do really believe that play area
should be investigated and gun cotton
way I think is very dangerous at present
I've had a club I wouldn't normally do
it from the chair but I mean you know
we're just going to go around in circles
so
um
had a complaint from somebody using the
Tesco Superstore that they were
overtaken on the wrong side of a Rhode
Island by truck a longer a long gun cut
away so yes I do think it does need a
proper Crossing
well I don't
know tin for um
children's play area I think would would
be critical so um John do you think you
could just drum something up on that or
are members happy with that or well wait
a minute do members wish to speak to my
proposal first of all counselor Caston
okay
thank you very much Madam chairman yeah
I think it does make sense what you're
saying I think there's there's actually
a design that could work for this and
the um
I've been on the um on um the Suffolk
County Council flood risk um scrutiny um
committee for a while and there's other
ways of dealing with this
um a basin can be replaced with
attenuation crates and then you've
created a grass area
that's flat and can be used as a play
area you've increased the usable area on
that site it may be a little bit more
expensive but um there's there's a gain
from having these extra houses
um I don't want to put too much
um ask for too much because we'll um
we'll get the previous
um plan which you know I'm sure people
aren't uh aren't
um especially upset about but I would
like to see these um houses these
starter homes and I think they'd be
useful but I think with if they um if
they look into this there's ways of
dealing with this without making it
unviable and I think this is the right
way forward this deferral I will be
supporting it thank you anyone else wish
to speak please councilor Humphreys yep
thank you I do agree with you it would
be really useful and I think we should
go down that route
um but don't like say let that be the
answer at the district councilors that
are involved in that Ward you need to
take it away after this meet for the
crossing
um and the other point I had was oh on
this
I can't remember it so I will be
supporting the deferment thank you I
have got points very important point
Sorry I don't know if I'm being confused
it's quite simply I could be or whether
I've lost a piece of paper or whether
it's missing so page 448 which I believe
should have the recommendations can you
just confirm that that's the page that
would have the recommendations
because if it is it doesn't seem to me
that it's set out as recommendations
I don't know if it's just a typo or me
recommendation on page 450 all right
okay I'm missing the page that's it
thank you yeah thank you very much I'm
not going to search for it
yeah thank you I'll go look for it now
um anyone else wishing to speak to my I
can see counselor stringer's hand Madam
chair councilor Stringer yeah yes chair
thank you uh very briefly just this is a
probably a classic case of of an
application it's not quite good enough
to approve it and not quite bad enough
for a straight out refusal it's one of
those so if if people could they've
heard the discussion they know there
could be areas for improvement or just
clarification if we can show how we can
get the bins and all of that kind of
stuff yes that would be rather wonderful
so yeah happy to defer but mindful that
for a developers at the moment time is
of the essence absolutely I don't want
to drag it out but um actually um as the
proposer um just to ask for Clarity on
the bins I think that would be
appropriate yes so when I ask somebody
here if I can um yeah so Gemma in terms
of the bins we've got nothing on plan
for that so no we do have plans and on
uh page now I think it was uh I have had
no objection from Waste Services but it
is at the very bottom of the page and it
falls off onto the next one uh
sorry but yes we have had plans they
provided initial comments we did some
moments and we've got confirmation that
you can get at bin Lori in and turn okay
that's fair enough then there's no need
to add anything else then but when you
bring it back again make sure that's
clear for presentation absolutely
whichever committee
um and uh just a question for Ian does
it have to come back to this committee
or that's normal isn't it when we've
decided yeah yeah I'm just trying to
move it along so that the developer
doesn't have to delay Madam chairman the
um I think I've discussed this issue
with Mr Carmichael quite recently in
another context and I think what we've
said is that there's basically an
Unwritten protocol that we goes back to
the same committee from The Good Sense
and so forth I think we've only once
broken that rule consciously when we had
to beat a stash retirement limits and we
just had to go to the other committee
but I think it would obviously be right
and wise for this to come back to be
committee yeah and and I do hope the
applicant understands our reasoning so
um you know we want to work with them
having worked so hard to get to where we
are anyone else wish to speak to the
motion
no in that case then Robert can you do a
vote on this then please that we defer
full clarity to see if a play area can
be encompassed within the plans thank
you
sorry so I'll just could I just confirm
anybody with Mr pateman G first just
before I put that into absolutely
into the voting
sorry I was having a few technical
difficulties
um I missed some of that
um in respect of the
um wording for deferral essentially
members are looking to see if a locally
equipped area play is
um possible to achieve within the site
in accordance with their policies uh
rt4 excellent yes
um which is essentially saying that for
development over 10 houses you would
look to seek uh four more areas of play
uh if they can't be satisfactory found
elsewhere so essentially
you are seeking to defer on the basis of
exploring possibilities of a Berkeley
area equipped at the locally equipped
area of play uh in accordance with your
policy rt4 I think that's about as much
as I need to say yeah are you happy with
that councilor Norris
no no we can't that's outside our that's
outside our remit on this planning thing
that will be something that the ward
members will have to pursue with the
County Council okay otherwise agreed yes
with what has been suggested yeah thank
you thanks uh Mike I don't wish to sort
of knock you back on it but that's the
best we can do at the moment
so just to confirm then sorry so that
this is I've got this down as
correct so that the application be
deferred to allow officers officers to
explore a I'll use the abbreviation of
leap in a court that's what it is isn't
it John sorry
Mr pateman G yes so it is uh l-e-a-p
local equipped area play in accordance
with rt4 that's what I've got down
yep
uh chair can I just button sorry to
muddy the waters
you can but I am changing it
thank you I saw the eye roll
um uh
is there any way we could secure a
contribution towards a proposed uh
Crossing through the Section 106.
I think it's outside our area on this
and that needs more than just putting a
Crossing in it would need um a um
yeah Jumping John
um okay there's two there's a couple of
issues here first of all you know have
we actually debated that there was
severe impact uh that would justify uh
the additional houses that are being
proposed here compared to the material
considerations of the last application
uh to justify that secondly ultimately
what you're dealing with is the county
and the County's adopted Road and of
course they've got no indication that
they would be wanting to put a a
Crossing across that road uh or sort it
in any shape or form so you would then
potentially be trying to essentially
Ransom strip in a way uh the development
can only go ahead rely on another party
and I think that would be a risk in that
context and I just don't think it's
appropriate to to start putting that in
now because they'd need a
um I mean for it to be severe I I they'd
have to do what's the word I'm looking
for um not a modeling they'd have to do
a um not a project what's the word I'm
looking for oh help me help me you know
when they do um
you know you're getting out of that's
why I said that the ward members can can
look at that and pursue that down that
road
along with the county councilor and so
on so I'm afraid councilor Mellon I
wouldn't be adding anything to my
proposal as much as I'd like to but I'm
not
thank you
right
shall we get on with it
yeah if you're ready then I will start
the vote
so members if you could please go to the
modern.gov app
and plus press the plus sign in the top
right hand corner and go on attendance
and voting
I've started the vote in progress and
you might need to scroll down to the
light blue bar
that's the string if I could take your
vote verbally please
oh no sorry my apologies Council
stronger it's worked fine
so chair I can confirm that that is a
unanimous vote for
The Proposal
thank you and thank you everybody thank
you very much indeed so moving on there
are no proposed site visits I don't
think or anything like that
um so
site inspections and underreport I
presume Robert to report you
so I'll formally close the meeting and
thank everybody for their attendance and
input thank you very much indeed thank
you Jeff thank you